hey what's up it's john from coding
addict and welcome to serverless
functions video
in this video we'll cover what are
serverless functions
and why we'd want to use them in the
first place essentially
why we should care after that we'll set
up two apis
first one a basic api with local data
and second one more complex api with
nice graphical interface and air table
as
our data storage what's really special
since we'll use
serverless functions we'll be able to
set up both apis
without even a single line of server
code
and backend hosting challenges also at
the very
end of the video i'll show you how to
add serverless functions
to your react app to give you a brief
origin of this video
if you watched my react tutorial and
projects videos
you know that i built some apis to
practice data fetching
in react since i was getting a lot of
questions
of how i was able to do it using
serverless functions
i decided to record a video where i
explain everything
in detail lastly before we continue let
me just quickly mention
that this video is part of my serverless
functions course
where we cover more interesting use
cases and
setups of serverless functions all right
and welcome to nutify serverless
functions course
and i guess let's start by answering the
most pressing
questions first what is a serverless
function
and why should we care so here's the
deal
there are times when our app needs a
dynamic feature
and even after that 20th
google search we come to realization
that the only way to do that
is by setting up our own server for
example
accepting stripe payment comes to mind
and while i have nothing against
node or express server building and
hosting a server
just for one feature has two major
issues
first it takes time and it can be
frustrating
especially the hosting part second it
seems like an overkill
to set up the whole server just to
handle single task
so that's where the serverless functions
come into play
you see with serverless functions we can
set up
our desired functionality with less
lines of code
than you would normally do it by setting
up the server
and still use our favorite programming
language which of course in our case is
javascript
and without entering the wonderful world
of backend and of course i'm not being
sarcastic again i like
working on a back end but there's times
when you simply want to get the feature
up and running instead of setting up the
whole server
now before we continue let me stress
something despite what the name suggests
serverless does not does not mean that
there is no server
it simply means that we as front-end
developers
are not responsible for maintaining it
so in short
serverless functions allow us to add
dynamic features to
our apps with little amount of code and
without the hassle of setting up the
server
if you would like to see all the
serverless function examples we're going
to work on
throughout the course feel free to visit
the url
serverless hyphen functions hyphen
course
dot nutify.app again the url
is serverless hyphen
functions hyphen course dot nullify
dot app and once you get there as you
can see
it's somewhat self-explanatory these are
all the examples we're going to cover
during the course feel free to poke
around and test them out
and you can do that just by clicking on
links
so for example this is going to be the
basic api
where essentially we'll set up our local
api
this is going to be a hard-coded data
then we also have one
with air table we're also going to have
example where we hide the api key so
we'll build the
weather app but the main goal of this
example is not to show you how to
build the weather app it is to show you
how we can use serverless
functions to hide our secret api keys
and also we have for example newsletter
and hopefully you get the gist
now i'm not going to spend half an hour
going over each and every example
just keep in mind that as you're
watching this in the future
i might add some more examples but
i would want to show you a very neat one
the stripe payment so i'm going to
navigate to the stripe payment
and if you're not familiar with stripe
payment
the way we can accept the payment
is not by directly communicating with
stripe
that is not allowed so essentially we
would need to have a server
that we would need to ping before we can
submit the payment and the reason why we
need to ping our own server
is because server would need to
communicate with stripe
on a background and get the client
secret
and only then when we get back that
client secret
from our own server from our own backend
only then we can submit the payment
otherwise of course it would be highly
insecure where somebody could come in
on our front end and do some bad stuff
now
i'll open up the dev tools because i
want to showcase
what is happening so i'm going to go
to the sources and i would want to show
you the app.js
so notice here in the app.js i have
hard-coded
this purchase so again normally this
would be some kind of cart
or a checkout page where essentially the
user has put some stuff in the cart and
now
he or she wants to check out but
again since our main goal is not the
front end i just hard coded
these purchases and in my array i have
two items
and i also have two values for total
amount
and shipping fee now this is a stripe
key that we can
show on a front end however notice how
the moment
page loads we actually communicate with
our serverless function and we can
clearly see that because the url is
pointing
to our own server and what we're doing
we're passing this data to the
serverless function
and then the serverless function in the
background communicates
with stripe and we can also see that if
we navigate to the network
and i'm just going to go with xhr and
fetch option
and if i refresh we can see that we are
making a fetch request
to our server list function so lan
serverless function returns that client
secret
that we need in order to submit the
payment and
only then the user can of course submit
the payment
so now of course i'll enter those test
values and some dummy values for the zip
code
and the date and now once we click pay
this is where we communicate
with stripe so again without setting the
whole server
we can set up this functionality with
very
little effort hopefully this gives you a
very good idea of what the serverless
functions can do
and i'll see you in the course when it
comes to serverless functions
pretty much all of the major cloud
providers
offer some variation of them but of
course
format will differ from service to
service
for this course we will use company by
the name of netflie
so in order to host your functions
basically deploy your project with
functions on the web
you'll need to sign up for a free
netflix account
if you don't have one already now before
we continue let me be very very clear
i'm not sponsored by netflix i have zero
affiliation with nullify
and at the end of the day i could care
less which provider
you end up using the reason why i picked
notify is because they offer
generous free tier and they make it very
easy to get up and running
with serverless functions even without
an account
you'll be able to test all the
functionality locally
and the main goal of the course is to
show you the endless world of
possibilities
serverless functions offer not to boost
a
affiliation program and while we're on a
topic of services
during the course in order to test some
features
you will need to create a few other free
accounts as well
for example air table for example stripe
button down and mail gun similar to
netflix
all of them have generous free tier and
the reason why i picked them
is because of easy setup not a
sponsorship
or affiliate program keep in mind that
it's impossible for me to show you
how for example email subscription works
without
using any external service and
if you are unhappy with my choice for
the service that i picked
there are plenty of alternatives you can
choose from
and even though format might differ
the main setup will be extremely similar
so if you don't have one already i would
suggest
navigating to nettlefi.com and
create a free account if you poked
around the examples you probably noticed
that i used straight up html css
and vanilla.js for the front end
and that was done on purpose you see
when it comes to serverless functions
essentially we have two parts we have
the frontend
that communicates with them and then we
have the serverless functions itself
now when it comes to front-end
serverless functions
are framework agnostic meaning
you can use them with any framework you
would like
because at the end of the day all we're
doing is sending
requests to specific endpoints and after
that doing something
based on the response i could have went
with react
my framework of choice but the reason
why i went bare bones html css and
javascript
is because i don't want to make it
difficult for people who use
different framework for example view the
general setup is exactly the same for
any framework you use just
implementation of course
will differ trust me if you can set up
functionality with vanilla.js you can
definitely do it
with any framework with that being said
the very end of the course we will build
an example app
with react and serverless functions
just because i keep getting these
questions how you do that
and also because the react currently
is the most popular front-end framework
and also there are some gotchas that i
would like to cover
when it comes to react app serverless
functions
and deploying them on metalfi as far as
course requirements go they're not that
many
my expectation is that you're familiar
with common
html tags simple css rules
and some basic vanilla js functionality
specifically http
or ajax requests and as far as the dev
environment setup
in order to follow along with the course
you will need
a node installed in your machine because
we'll use some
npm packages so if you don't have it
already
please install node on your machine
now since it's somewhat of a advanced
course
and it's very hard to troubleshoot your
local environment
i'm not going to cover node install
essentially
it's as straightforward as it gets just
navigate to
nodejs.org pick the operating system
and then answer yes to all the questions
if you hit some roadblocks please
utilize your favorite
search engine since like i already
mentioned it's extremely hard for me to
troubleshoot your local environment if
you type
node version in your terminal and you
get a version number
you are in good shape so navigate to
nodejs.org pick the operating system
which by the way they already
suggest for you then pick the version
you would like to install
and then once you're done answering yes
to
all the questions you should be able to
navigate to your terminal or command
prompt
if you're using windows and then you can
just type no dash
version and if you get the version
number back
you are in good shape and you can move
on to the next video
when it comes to my text editor i prefer
using visual studio code
but of course you can follow along with
a course even if you use different text
better
as far as extensions and settings all
default config
options are just fine now if you are
interested
in my overall setup and extensions that
i use
just head on over to my github and look
for the repo
vs code setup all caps
so let's imagine that you are interested
in my text editor setup
like i said just navigate to my account
which is
john smilga and then look for
all caps vs dash code dash
setup and in the readme you'll find all
the extensions
that i use and a short explanation of
what the extension is doing and if you
want to see my settings
just navigate to settings json and
here you'll be able to find my text
error settings
in order to follow along with the course
you'll need a star project
and you can get it by visiting
johnsmilk.com
then the url is johnsmilk.com
and once you get to the site just scroll
past the courses
i mean if you want of course you can
enroll in serverless functions course
but what you're looking for are the
projects
and if it is not in the latest project
just click on all the projects and then
more specifically
you can filter for serverless and
then in the card you have three links
you can
visit the complete project you can take
a look at the complete
source code and what you're looking for
are the starter files and then once you
navigate to the repo
again the repo name is serverless
functions
starter then you can just continue
watching the videos
beautiful and once we navigate to the
repo
we have few options we can clone it we
can
fork it or we can simply download and i
think in my case
i'm gonna go for clone option so i'm
gonna grab
this url and i'm gonna navigate back to
my desktop
open up my terminal zoom in just so you
can see that there's no cheating
and i'm gonna go with cd desktop so now
of course i'm navigating to desktop
if only i could type though so desktop
and then we're gonna run git clone
and then we pass in the url
then i'm gonna use my text error
and i'm just gonna open up new window
drag and drop
the folder and before we do anything
before we go
over the setup which is something that
i'm going to do in the next video
i would want to do two things first i
want to remove the
remote url from the git so essentially
i'm just going to remove the whole git
folder
so that way when you initialize a new
git repo
it's not going to be pointing to my repo
because that is important
and then the second thing will install
all the dependencies and again
i'll talk about the dependencies and the
whole setup in
next video but since it takes time we
might as well do that right now
so at the moment i opened up the
integrated terminal in visual studio
code
and the command is control and tilde
and by the way you can find it here as
well so we need to go to view
and then let me zoom in command you're
looking for is this one
where we open up the terminal like i
said first i'll
remove the git folder and then we'll
create one
from the scratch so in the mac the
command
is rm rf and then git
and if you're using windows please
google the
alternative method for windows so now i
remove the git repo
and now of course i'll create a new one
so we're going to go with
get in it so that creates a new
repository
now i would want to install all the
dependencies that i have in a
package.json
and the way we do that we run npm
install
that's all that's all we have to do we
run that
and then like i said next video i'll
cover the general
setup of the star project and before we
enter the wonderful world
of serverless functions let me just
quickly cover
what you are going to find in star
project so we have one folder
for the assets so these are the assets
we're going to use
throughout the project as you can see
they're not that many of them
there's few images as well as data.js
file
and of course i'll talk about them when
we actually use them
then we have examples folder where
we'll do half of our work so the other
half is going to be
in the serverless functions folder which
we haven't created yet and i'm going to
talk about
the examples at the end of the video
because i think it's just going to make
a bit more sense then we have git ignore
since we're using the source control
since we're using git
these are just files that are going to
be ignored
and of course the most important ones
are the node modules
and by the way if you want to see node
modules just click refresh
because of course we ran npm installs so
we should have the
node modules folder and also we have dot
env
where we're going to keep our secrets
then we have
global css so this is just a css file
with my general styles as well as index
html and you might be tempted to open
this up
straight up in a browser and technically
you can do that since we do have the
index html
however there's one gotcha and let me
show you the gotcha
so for example i can navigate to the
folder you can see that i have the
index.html
and i simply double click and
technically
yeah i can see that the app is working
however
it's not going to work when it comes to
the
serverless functions why well because in
order to run
our servers functions the network
serverless functions
we need to run them on the server
so we have two options either every time
we're going to make some kind of update
we need to push our project
to production essentially we need to
redeploy it to netflix
which as you can guess is a bit annoying
and the other setup is actually using a
package
the netfly package the nullify cli
package
that sets up that production environment
on our local machine and that was one of
the reasons
why we have this package.json and if
you're not familiar with package.json
essentially it is a manifest file for
our project and essentially this is a
node app and the way it works we have in
a package just on all the packages that
we're going to be using
now let me repeat what i said already
before
where our front end is going to be
framework agnostic so our front end is
still going to be
vanilla html vanilla css
and vanilla javascript however these are
the packages
that we're going to use on our back end
essentially
when we're setting up our serverless
functions
and let me also mention that if you're
not familiar with node
don't panic effectively there are only a
few things you need to know
package.json is a manifest file for the
project
so this is where we have our
dependencies
node modules is the folder where we keep
all dependencies
and the last thing is going to be the
import and export syntax
which i'm going to cover once we create
our first
function and again the whole point of
the serverless functions
is that you don't need to know those
things about node
you don't need to know how to set up the
express server
or something along those lines so if
you're not familiar with node
again don't stress about it there's not
much you need to know
and with that said in package.json
in dev dependencies you'll find package
by the name of
nettlefie cli and what this package
allows us to do is to set up
that netfly production environment
on our local machine because we install
that netlife cli and then we have
access to the command of netlify dev
the way i did it i set up a command
by the name of netfly so you just need
to run npm
run nutify and that will spin up the
nettlefi dev server so let's try to do
that
in a console i'll clear everything i'm
just going to run
npm run metalfi
now before we continue let me just
mention something
where normally you would install this
globally
and the command of course for that one
would be npm
or i guess in a mac you would need to
add sudo since you're installing
globally
and then the command would be sudo npm
install hyphen g and then notify cli
because of course that way you can use
that package
in all your projects and nullify cli
does
more than what we're going to do
throughout the course
for example you can even log into your
account and
do all kinds of cool stuff and that's
why you would install this globally so
you can use it
in every project now the reason why i
went the local route
why i wasn't showing how to install
globally
because most of the time when i
introduced some kind of global package
to any of my courses there's always this
one student who gets
all kinds of bugs and then gets really
frustrated
so as a test run i decided to add this
to the dependencies so essentially to
avoid
installing global package we'll see how
it goes
maybe it's going to fail miserably but
hopefully it works better where this is
just added to dependencies so then you
install
you don't need to install anything
globally this is added
right away to your dependencies and then
of course
you can right away use it now the reason
why i'm telling you that because once in
a while
you might see me type this
you might see me typing netlify nettlefy
dev directly because of course i have
installed this globally
so maybe sometimes automatically i might
type that
now don't freak out again i'm not
cheating essentially you can still run
this npm around netfly
and it will still work this is a command
so of course you can change it if you
don't like the name
just remember to run npm run first and
then
whatever is the new command name
if you changed it and once we run the
npm run netlify
we spin up the dev server and once we
spin this up
we should see a nice info
that our server is running on http
and then localhost 888.
now let me mention something where yes
in our case of course we're using
just straight up index html and of
course since the index.html
is a root that's why we're right away
directed
to our homepage but if for example
you have for your front end a react app
or you have a gatsby app or swelt or
whatever
metal vice cli he is very smart where
netflix cli
is gonna detect what front end are you
using
and it's gonna spin up that server as
well now again this is
a little bit outside of the scope on
this course but i just want to let you
know that you're not
limited to running netlify
cli only with just straight up
vanilla html you of course can do that
with your
favorite framework as well and once you
navigate here like i said will be served
this homepage and what's really cool
is the fact that now of course we can
set up our functions
because essentially we have this
production
environment on our local machine
now one downside to this one and of
course we'll cover that once we get to
the functions
is the fact that every time you create a
new function so not when we modify
some existing function but every time we
create a new function
we need to stop the server and we do
that by
ctrl c and then spin it up from the
scratch so again we go with npm
run and then nutlify or if you have
installed the package globally like i
have you just run
ntl dev which is just short for metal
file
you run this and one downside of that is
that it opens up
another new tab so that's a bit annoying
where
again every time we create a function
and of course in our case
there's going to be quite a few
functions that we're going to create
well then of course we need to set it up
from the scratch and we'll have this new
tab
unfortunately that is the current setup
hopefully by the time you're watching
this
it's not the case anymore but if it is i
guess that would be
one downside of this whole setup but
apart from that it is really great
because again we can have this
production environment
on our local machine so let me close
this tab and notice here this is of
course
going to be my final project where i'm
going to be showing you
how the examples are going to look like
and you know what while we're still at
it let's go to index.html you'll see
that
there's not much to it pretty typical
index.html file i'm just going to go
with serverless functions
and i'm just gonna say here start or you
know what
i'm just gonna delete the whole thing
and i'm just gonna say starter here
so that way when i look at the tabs i
can see that this is a complete project
and this is going to be my starter so we
have this nav here
where we can just navigate back to the
home page so as we're going to be
navigating
from example to example we can always go
back home
and that's it we just have a list and
each list item just points to examples
directory
and in there we have folder for every
example
and in that folder since again we're
just using
straight up vanilla approach with
index.html and css
as well as app.js we are just pointing
to the index.html in that folder
so that's why when you navigate back to
the homepage you can see that
once you click here of course this is
going to be our first example
then you can go to the air table one of
course we still have the loading because
we haven't set up the functionality
but hopefully you get the gist where
every time we're gonna work on a project
you'll simply navigate in your browser
to that particular project
and then in the visual studio code in
your text editor
of course we'll also navigate to that
folder and set up
the front end now i purposely added this
star here as well
and this is the folder that i used as a
starter for
all my examples and then of course i
modified them
as i set up the example so in the
examples directory like i said you'll
find
all the examples we're going to work on
and then what you're going to find in a
folder
all the folders are going to have this
index.html
which is just going to have some css so
notice here how we're importing
global css but there's also going to be
a specific
style css just for this project
and the reason why i added that just in
case you would ever want to check hey
listen how he did
this or that css you can find this
styles css so there you'll find styles
specifically to that project but if you
want to see the global ones of course
just navigate to the global css and
you'll find the files
again there's not much to it but if you
ever want to
see how i set up some kind of css you
can definitely do it in a global
or the particular one for the project
and then i can tell you honestly that
most of our work we're going to do here
in the app.js since this is somewhat of
a advanced course and i don't want to
waste your time
on setting up the html and css
html and css is prepared now the only
thing we will need to do
on our front end is to work on the logic
so this is where we'll communicate back
and forth with our
serverless functions and if at the
moment this makes sense trust me
by the time we're done with first
example it's going to be clear
how and why we're doing that and the
last thing that i would want to mention
all the front-end examples we can set up
with
built-in fetch api
it's definitely doable now i went with
script here and i'm importing here axios
and if you're not familiar with axios
it's just an
awesome front end library that we use
to set up our request or http request
now why i went with ax here is because
in my opinion
they have a bit cleaner api so it's a
bit
easier to use especially since our main
focus
is serverless functions so i wouldn't
want to waste
too much of your time by writing lines
and lines of code
with the fetch setup that's number one
and
also in my opinion their error handling
is way better
where we get a bit more clearer messages
of what are the errors and that's going
to be very important when we're setting
up our
serverless functions that's why in here
in the
index.html for every project you'll get
the script
where effectively i'm just getting the
axios library and that's why in our
app.js
where we'll set up our logic we'll have
access to the library
that's why we'll be able to do it but
again you can
set up everything using fetch
you don't have to use access it's not
like just because we're using serverless
functions we need to use axios now
you can definitely use fetch and by the
way stripe example
is going to be wood fetch because that's
what comes from
stripe docs that's our general setup
like i said
we have index.html where we can navigate
from one project
to another project and now of course
i think we're ready to build our first
netlify
serverless function all right all right
i know that you're eager
to start working on our servers
functions
so let's create our first one i'm gonna
close
all the tabs that i have currently open
in my text editor
and also in here i mean we can leave the
url because we'll change it in a second
anyway
so i guess the tab can stay the way it
is
and we need to do two things first we
would need to set up
netlify tamil file where we tell
netlify where the functions are located
and then of course we need to create a
functions folder
with our first function so let's do
first the tamu file
so we need to navigate to the root and
the place is very important so please do
that in the root don't do it in examples
or assets so i'm gonna zoom in
just so you can see a bit better i'm
gonna go with
new file and then the name is nutlify
and then dot and thoma file so
the code inside of this file is going to
tell
info to the null file so notify is going
to know
what to do with our functions and some
extra custom setup that we're going to
add
a bit later so that's number one and
then number two
we need to create that functions
directory so again
in the root we're gonna go with new
folder and we're going to call this
functions and then i'm going to zoom out
actually
and notice here how i'm toggling the
sidebar and i do that with command of
command b and i'm going to start in my
netify tamil file and the syntax is
following
where we go with build and then we just
say
functions and then the location of
our folder so i go here with functions
is
equal and then since my functions is
located in a root we just go with
dot forward slash functions and then
we add the quotation mark so that's the
syntax okay then once we're done with
our netflix tunnel file now of course we
need to go
to the functions directory so again let
me zoom in
just so you can see and then we would
want to create a new file
now i'm a bit annoying where i like to
have
all my functions in order definitely you
don't have to do that but in my case
since i'll have multiple functions i
like to do
one and then hyphen and then the name
now
it is a bit harder later to access it of
course
it would be easier if would we just
hello but in my case
i'm sorry i'm just a bit annoying where
i like to have my functions in order so
when they're displayed they're gonna be
one hyphen hello
and then second hyphen and then the name
of the function
you don't have to do that but in my case
that is going to be
my approach so we're gonna go with one
hyphen and then hello
now the function name is really up to
you just later
when you try to access the function if
you name this function
differently please also use your own
name
don't complain if you cannot access your
function
using my name so we need to go with one
hyphen hello js like so
or however you would want to call your
function just add the js
extension and the way we're going to do
that
let me quickly type the most basic
syntax
let's get it up and running so we can
see that our function works
and then in the next video i'll cover
every piece of syntax in great detail
so we need to go here with exports which
just signals that we're exporting
and we're going to be exporting a
function by the name of handler
and this function needs to be async we
have access to few parameters
that netflix provides and you can call
them
shake and bake or taco or barrier or
whatever
but a common practice is calling
them event and context and then there's
optional
callback one that i'm going to cover in
next video and i'm going to set this up
as a arrow function as you can see and
then we always always want to return
from this function as you can see we're
returning
a object but of course since this is a
sync and by the way
messed it up it should have been here
async my bad
and then as you can see we're returning
object but we know that
from a synchronous function of course we
are returning
a promise and again something that i'm
going to talk about it
in greater detail next video but as far
as the logic
inside of this object we go with status
code and we're going to go here
with 200 and then the body so
essentially
what data are we returning and
i'm simply going to go with our first
and let me just capitalize them just
because i'm annoying
and we'll say function
example and that's it that's all we have
to do
now we should be able to access this
function
if we navigate to our domain which of
course in our case
is localhost 888 but then
once we set this up in production it's
going to be
our actual domain and then we go with
forward slash
dot nutlify and then forward slash and
then whatever
is the name now you don't need to add js
but in my case of course that is going
to be
one hyphen hello but notice how i said
should because if you remember
in the previous video i mentioned that
every time we create a new
function we need to stop the server
first
and then we need to run npm
run and then of course the name was
nettle phi
or if you have it globally then ntl dev
so once we spin the sucker up
now of course like i said it's going to
be annoying where we're going to get
a new tab and then in the url
again let me zoom in just so you don't
think
that i'm making this up we need to go
with forward slash
then notify and as you can see i have a
bunch of examples already
and we need to go with metalfi functions
and then the name and you know what i
think i made a bug over there
so we need to go with a netlify and then
functions here
my apologies should be forward slash
functions
forward slash and then the name of the
function
so we go here with functions and then
the name of the function which of course
in my case is hello
so once we go here check it out
we have our first netlify
function example which is extremely
extremely cool now if you think that i'm
overreacting
just because i'm so happy to see one
string displayed on the screen trust me
when i say this
if you have ever set up the
express server that just serves this one
simple string
you know that you need to jump through
way
more hoops than one two three
four five six lines of code that's it
that's all we have to do
in a matter of few minutes we have back
end
up and running that of course eventually
will do
way more than just serving up
the e string but like i said if you have
ever
set up the express server you know that
just the setup is way more lines of code
and then when it comes to deployment
it's even more hassle
but with serverless functions that's all
we have to do
we need to tell netlify in a tamil file
where the functions are located and the
syntax is build
and then functions is equal to the
folder
which in our case of course is the
functions and then
in the functions folder we need to
create a function
and we just do that by creating the js
file with some kind of name
which in my case is one hyphen hello
then we have the syntax which i'm going
to talk about
in greater detail in the next video and
then
once we set up the function
then of course we can access that
function in the domain
then dot netify functions and then the
function name that's all that's all we
have to do
and that's where the real magic starts
because we can do
all kinds of functionality in this
function
and then return all kind of
cool data even though at the moment you
can just see
our string of our first nullify
function example and once we have our
first
function up and running now of course
let's dissect the syntax and we're going
to start with this export
so what's up with this beast well we
need to understand that
we are in the node ecosystem
and in node there is a different syntax
for exporting
and importing so if you're familiar with
es6
modules you know that the import and
export statements
are following where we go with import
and then the name and then from
or if we're exporting we can go with
export and then named
export or we have export default and
then whatever
is the name so in node they use this
common js syntax where essentially we go
with exports
and then there's also module.exports
where essentially we export
from this file that's it that's all
we're doing and then of course after the
dot we need to specifically say well
what
are we exporting and in our case as you
can see we're exporting
a function and the name here is
important so netflix is looking for this
function by the name of handler so don't
call this
shake and bake and as far as the
function that we're exporting
you're probably wondering hey what's up
with this why there's a
sink over here but essentially we're not
using a weight well the reason for that
because we need to return
a promise and we know that every
asynchronous function by default will
return a promise and the third parameter
that we can access
is actually callback so
if you don't like this approach then we
can also set up the callback
so how's that going to look like well
i'm going to comment this out because of
course
we will go back to it because in my
opinion the syntax is a bit cleaner
but if you don't want to go the async
route you can just
remove the async and then call the
callback function
and then the first parameter is the
error which of course in our case
is null and then we do the same thing
where basically
we return a object over here or we pass
in the object that would be probably a
bit more correct
and we go with status code and i'm going
to go with 200
and then also i'll say body and let's
just change it around and say
hello world and exclamation point so
once i save like i previously mentioned
we don't have to restart the server
now when we go in the browser and
navigate to
the network functions and then one
hyphen hello
we should see the hello world so
this is another approach you can take
but like i said in my opinion
the async approach is a bit cleaner
that's why throughout the course
we'll stick with that one so let me
delete
the callback line and i'm going to go
back to
async function and of course this
is what we're returning now what about
the
other two parameters that are supplied
by netify well the event is going to
have a bunch of useful
info about the incoming request
and second don't worry we'll cancel log
it so it's going to make a bit more
sense
and then the second thing is the context
so this is going to explain the context
where the function is running and we're
not going to use this in this course but
you can get for example a very useful
info if you use
the netflies authentication
setup and the name for that setup is
identity
i believe and there for example you can
get the info
about the user that is accessing the
function again
we'll cancel log both of them but
throughout the course
we'll mainly use the event now keep in
mind one thing though
when we console log these parameters
we'll be console logging them here on
the server
and in our case of course that server is
going to be here in the terminal
so there's two places we of course can
cancel log
also in the front end and then of course
we'll check
for the responses in the browser in this
case when we're console logging
we're not going to logging in the
browser will be console logging
on a server so let me just go here with
event
first let's save and then of course now
we need to
navigate to our function one more time
and that's when we will
invoke the function and that's when we
can see the
info about the incoming request so for
example
this is going to tell us the path this
is going to tell us the http method
and don't worry i'm going to talk about
the methods
in later videos then we have for example
query string parameters
and all kinds of useful info and don't
worry
once we get to specific example
of course if we'll use the event i'll
talk about
that specific property in great detail
since i don't see the point
of covering every single property
that is on that event object and the
second thing
is going to be the context where we do
the same thing we go with context
i'll save it again we need to invoke the
function so we navigate to the url
and once we come back here like i said
this is just going to have
a bunch of useful info about the context
that the function is running and then
for example
this is going to be that client context
where you can get the info
about the user if you're for example
using netfly identity
but we're not going to have that example
in the course
so i'll leave the callback for now just
for your info i will
remove the console and now of course we
arrive at the return
so there's two things that we need to
return we need to return
a status code and i'll spend the next
video
talking about the status code so for now
just remember that
200 is a success
and then we need to have a body now we
always always always
always want to return a string
that's a must so you cannot pass in the
object
now the difference is that if you have
the object
you can stringify it so let me showcase
of course in our case we just have the
string all together so we just pass it
and we're good to go but imagine the
scenario where you have const
and i'm not going to be particularly
original i'm just going to say person
and the name will be john
if you try to pass this sucker into the
body
and you'll say body is equal to the
person
there's going to be a big fat error and
there it is we have
your function response must have a
string body you gave
object blah blah blah blah blah and then
in my console in the browser console
i can see that hey listen there's an
error
we don't have any more the status code
of 200
we have essentially 500 and if i go back
to my terminal i can also see the error
now in order to avoid that we simply go
with
json and then there's a method of
stringify
and we pass in our object
so if you have any other data type
apart from the string then of course you
need to stringify it so i'm talking
about arrays i'm talking about
objects and all that so let me go back
and now there it is so i'm kind of
skipping ahead a little bit
because this is our second example where
we'll set up the api but
you should see this value
in the console and now let me see what
is my zoom level yeah that should be
150 so and we are in good shape
so those are the basics about the syntax
of course this is the most basic example
there's going to be more things that
we're going to add to it
but we have exports which just say that
we're exporting
this is a function by the name of
handler
i'm just setting this up as an arrow
function we set this up as
async because it returns a promise
and that is very important and then we
have event
and context parameters that are being
supplied
by the nucleophile so there's nothing we
need to do
with that they're just being supplied we
will have to dissect some values
later on if we would ever want to access
them and not in a function
body we always always want to return
an object with at least status code and
then the body
so notice what happens if we don't do
anything for example
i'm just going to comment everything out
again we have the error because lambda
response was undefined
check your function code as well so
notify is like hey listen buddy
i'm kind of hanging here what is
happening why there's no return that's
why we need to return
we have status code that we're going to
cover in greater detail next video
and then the body that always always
needs to be
a string so for reference i'm just going
to comment this out
of course but we're going to go back to
our previous example
and i believe that was what our first
metal phi function or something along
those lines
so let me go with body r
first nutlify nutlify
function example and i would also
suggest going back to the string because
we'll use that
in our first example so
just change it back to the string that
should do it
and i'll see you next video all right so
we're clear about the syntax that we
currently have
in our first serverless function
but what's up with this sucker the
status code
why do we need that and in order to
explain it better
i'm going to use my favorite friend by
the name
of google and essentially i would want
you to google two things first of all
let's go with http
request and then the second is going to
be
the http status code
now for request i want you to go to the
images
and i'll explain why in a second and the
second
search is going to be http status codes
and here most likely the first resource
is going to be linked to mozilla website
so that's of course
where i would want you to navigate so
big picture what's happening every time
we open up our browser
we are sending http messages
http request so imagine that this is
going to be
our computer and this is the server
now i'm purposely going with google
images i'm not creating my own because
that way
you can check which image actually makes
the most sense for you
in my case i think i'm going to go with
this one where essentially we have
our laptop or our computer or whatever
and we're sending a request to the
server
now in this cycle we are using
those http status codes to tell
to communicate between the client and
the server hey
the request was successful or
there was some kind of error so we send
in
the request and then we're getting back
the response
now in our case we need to understand
that yes of course
the client is still going to be our
browser
or our users browser
but then the request is going to be
coming from our
serverless function and please keep in
mind that
every browser by default is going to be
performing
a http get request now i'll talk about
the methods a little bit later but
just understand that not only we're
going to be setting this up
from our examples for example first one
is going to be the hello world
but also every time you visit a site
using your browser
essentially you are by default
performing a http
get request and that's why you're
getting back the response
so every time you open up the browser
and you navigate somewhere
you're getting the response from that
server whether that is google whether
that is facebook or whatever
any site you visit and essentially why
we have status codes well because we're
communicating
the browser is sending a request and
then the server
is responding and when it comes to
status codes we're just communicating
what's happening with the request and as
you can see once we navigate to
the mozilla website we can see that http
response status codes indicate whether
a specific http request has been
successfully
completed and there's a few brackets
so we have the informational ones from
100 to 199
then successful ones redirects and of
course you can
read the rest now i would strongly
discourage you from spending your
weekend
on memorizing those status codes for a
few reasons
one initially your applications won't
use that many of them
so you just need to remember a few of
them and then the second one
once you get to the point in your
application where you actually want to
have some kind of
specific status code essentially you can
just google them
again in my opinion memorizing all of
them
is going to be a big waste of your time
and like i said in the beginning we only
need to know a few of them
so 200 is going to be okay which just
means that request
has succeeded and that's going to be
forget
put post and trace another useful is 201
which just signals that the resource has
been created
and it's going to make more sense once
we cover the post request
because at the moment we'll just focus
on get request
which essentially just means that we got
the resource
that we requested from the server
so those are two successful ones that
are going to be very useful
and when it comes to errors
we have bad requests so that would be
400
that just means that there was something
wrong with the way requested
the resource for example there could be
invalid syntax
and then we have also 404 where we
for example cannot find the resource
and then also we have this 500
which is just a general server error
so if you really don't know what to put
you can just go with 500
and you can say hey listen there was
some kind of error on a server
now let me be very very very very clear
where we are the kings of the castle
here
we are the ones who are setting up this
response so
technically nothing stops me from saying
all right that's my function but the
status code is not going to be 200 it's
not going to be success
i can say you know what it's going to be
404 and yet
i'll still say uh
the request quest was
hopefully i'm spelling this correctly
is your data
so save this and now of course once i
invoke the function one more time
i have this confusing information where
the request was successful
here's my data and yet in a browser i
can see that it's 404
now just because you can do it doesn't
mean you should
because what you'll end up doing is just
confusing whoever
is using your api essentially
using your serverless function because
from one hand yeah we're getting the
data but then from the other one
we are getting the error response so
just because you can't do it you
shouldn't do it
every time you're setting up those
returns yes you should think about it
hey is this an error so if it is an
error
then i should probably use one of the
error codes now if it is a success
then of course i should use one of the
success codes again
most likely you'll be sticking with 200
or
201 if you are creating a resource
using a post request so that's the
general info
that's why when we're setting up our
function
we go with this property of course this
is a nettle file thing where you need to
add this
status code and then you just go with
one of those
codes and most likely it's going to be
200 which just means that
it is a success and then we just type
whatever we have in our response
now if it is going to be an error if
we're going to go with
404 then of course we'll just supply
the message the error message that we'll
consume
later in the browser so i'll save it
back to 200
our first netify function example and
then in the next video
we'll consume it in our first
example directory all right so
we have our first function we understand
the syntax we understand the status code
now the next big question is what can we
do with this
i mean it is a function i mean it's nice
to navigate to dotnetlife.functions and
hello
and see our awesome message but what can
we practically
do with this data well we could for
example
set up some kind of front end where once
we navigate
that page we fetch the data
fetch our message and dynamically
display it for the user and this is
exactly what we're going to do
so we're going to navigate to examples
folder
and then in the examples folder we're
not looking for the starter
again starter was just there for your
info
we're navigating to hello and then like
i said
we have three files we have index.html
which is essentially going to be the
page that is displayed once we navigate
to that particular url and then in the
index.html
we have some global styles we have style
css we have the nav
that allows us to navigate back to the
homepage where we have all our examples
and then here we have heading one with
the text the first example
and then we have the setting to the
class of result
and then like i said we have two scripts
one for axiorys
and one for general abgs and then of
course
we have the style css which like i said
it's not going to have much we just have
the heading 1 styles and like i also
previously mentioned
all of our work we're going to do here
in the app.js
so here's what i would want to do i
would want to select
that heading 2 with the class of result
and then once user navigates to the page
i'll dynamically fetch my message
from the body and of course display it
inside of this heading two
again this is just going to be done
using vanilla javascript
you need to keep in mind that of course
you can set up whatever frontend
framework you would like and then do the
same thing
functionality won't change the
implementation is of course going to be
different because
we are using the vanilla
js so here what i would want is to
select this result
so let me just open this in the app.js
and i'm going to say const result and
we're looking for document and the way
we've selected
is using the query selector and since
the class is a result
this is what i'm going to do i'm going
to select my result
and next i would want to fetch my data
and you know what let me try to zoom in
a bit in my visual studio code because
that way i think you'll
see it a bit cleaner and now i want to
set up
my function now right away set up async
since this is going to be a synchronous
action and we're going to go with const
and i'll call this
fetch data and like i said this is going
to be a synchronous function
it's going to be a arrow function and
we'll right away go with fetch
data i'll invoke it and for starters
let's just go with console.log
and we'll say fetch data called
like so so let's save it now i'm going
to navigate
back to my browser and i'm going to be
looking here and not
for my functions example i think i'm
going to open up a new tab
i'm going to go with 888 and this is
where i'll have all my examples now we
navigate
to hello world so that's the page we go
with examples
first hello and then index.html and then
once we expect
we should see in the console fetch data
call
if that works then of course we can
proceed and i would always suggest
setting up these kind of guardrails so
that way
you don't spend half an hour looking for
a bug that doesn't exist
now since our request is going to be
asynchronous
i would want to set up try and catch
so remove this console log and we'll
just say here
try catch and in a try block
we'll await four axios
again like i previously mentioned we
have access to the axios because
i set up those script tags so we're
going to go here with const
data and that is equal to await so now
we're
waiting for that promise to resolve
and with axiorys you can go with axios
and then supply the url
by default this is going to be get but
since there's going to be
few methods that we're going to use i'll
be more explicit and i'm just going to
say
axios.get which just means
that we're going to be performing a http
get request so we're getting some
resources
from the server which in our case is our
serverless function and it has a very
nice
api where we just simply provide the url
so what is our url well
it is on the same server so we don't
need to go with localhost 888
because of course eventually we'll
deploy this
but we do need to add a forward slash
then netlify then functions and then
whatever
is the name of the function correct so i
add here quotation marks
then forward slash then nutlify
pretty much i'm just copying whatever i
have over here
it's just the domain that i don't need
to include then i go with functions
functions and by the way in next video
we'll take a look at how we can shorten
this up
there's going to be a sweet shortcut and
then we're going to go with
1 and then hello so that's
my function and also of course i would
want to
cancel log the error if there is one
or display it if essentially would want
to do that
now for time being i'll just leave it
blank and i'll go over what we're
getting back
once we fetch the data now one thing
that i want
is to console log this data
and also cancel log the error now what's
really cool
about the axios when it comes to error
we need to go with error and
then response and this is the case where
it's much more useful info
than the typical fetch api which of
course is built
in the browser now one thing that you
might get these
weird syntax for the axiorys
so simply just remove it if that is the
case if you get it
so now let me navigate back to
my first example i'll invoke it and now
check it out
this is the data that we're getting back
so that's the data that i'm console
logging this is that big thing that
comes back
with axios so here we can see the
headers we can see the request
you can see the status we have the
status text
and all kinds of useful info now
what we're really interested is this
data
so in this data we're going to have
the body that we're sending back
whether that is simple string whether
that is going to be an array once we set
up
the api and along those lines so
that's what we are looking for so in
here what i
could do is right away this structure
the data
because the property name as you can see
is data
so what you'll see in a future examples
i'll simply
right away the structure the data
because that's what essentially we're
looking for
and now of course once i cancel log i
should only see that message
and there it is our first nutify
function
example and if of course the
request is successful what i would want
to do well i'm going to go with my
result which i
selected with my query selector then
we're going to go with text content
and we'll simply set it equal to my data
again this is just vanilla javascript
property that allows us to
set the text content of the node equal
to something which of course in our
cache is the data
so once i navigate back to the browser i
refresh
i have our first notify function example
beautiful
and if i go back to my hello and if i'll
simply say
hello world what do you think i'm going
to have there
i should have hello world right so there
is now of course i have the
hello world and hopefully this
emphasizes
how powerful the serverless functions
are when essentially
now i can right away connect them to my
front end
and do all kinds of cool things
and now let's also test it out the error
and in this case i'm going to go with
404
so that's going to be the error code and
i'll say
resource not found so resource
not not found here let's do that one
let's save it and once i refresh
i shouldn't have nothing here why well
because i have try
catch block and my arcgis so
i'm looking for the data but if there is
an error
then of course at the moment i'm just
constantly logging error
dot response and this is going to be the
same thing where we get back this
nice giant object but most likely what
we're going to be looking for
is this data over here so as you can see
the status is 404
the status text by default is going to
be right away not found
that's why i said that even though we
are
in charge of our own serverless function
and we can definitely do whatever we
would want
as you can see for example the library
sees 404
and right away attaches the status text
of not found
so yes you are king of the castle you
can do whatever you want but it's just
going to be very confusing
to people or even probably to yourself
when you're consuming the data that
you're getting back
from your own server and of course when
i say server i mean the
serverless function and most likely what
we're going to be looking for is again
this
data so again that's something that
you're going to see
throughout the course where i'll simply
go with error
dot response and then dot data
just understand that i'm right away
looking for the property because that's
the value
that i would want to see and there it is
now once
i refresh i see resource not bound
now if you want of course you can do the
same thing
you can go with result then text content
and set it equal to the data and now
once i refresh
and of course it says data is not
defined because yeah
i have in tri-clutch as data and here i
just have error
response and then data my apologies
and let's refresh one more time now we
have resource
not found again if we change the status
code but leave the same
message of course it's not going to
change
what we're displaying we're still
sending this
data back in the body but what we should
see
is different response here notice
now it is a bad request and again if we
go back to app.js
and ifill comes a log response you're
going to see
the different status text correct
because the library is reading the
status code of 400
and right away attaching this status
request hopefully it is clear now let me
go back
to the one hello and of course we're
going to go
back to the 200 let me just do it with
command z i think it's going to be
faster
instead of dealing with
deletions and rewriting everything so
let me save it
and we should see first example and our
first
netify function example text displayed
and before we start working on our next
example
i want to make our lives a bit easier
and i would want to set up redirect as
well as a remove
with the vs code setting for auto
suggestion
and we're going to start with redirect
you see at the moment
life is beautiful in the app.js we
fetch the data from dot netify forward
slash functions forward slash
one hello and of course then we can
display it
on the screen but wouldn't be nicer if
the path
would be shorter for example we could
set up
forward slash api forward slash one
hello and that's exactly what we can do
with a redirect in netflie so now i'm
going to open up
this sidebar and we need to navigate to
metalfi tamil file and please please
please please do not touch the functions
code
leave that one alone but below it we
need to set up this interesting syntax
where we go with two square brackets
then we type redirect and then we have
three values now for time being we'll
just add two and then i'll show you why
we would want to do the
third one as well and here we need to
provide
from and there's going to be some kind
of url in here
and two and again there's going to be
some kind of url
and essentially you can already guess
that since we're dealing with
redirect now i need to supply what i'm
going to be redirected
from and we're going to be redirecting
user to and this is where we need to get
creative
and we need to come up with a name for
the resource
and my case i'm just going to go with
api so essentially
on my server all the functions i'm going
to be setting up
in the resource by the name of api
so if you want to navigate to the
functions then the user has to go to
forward slash api and then forward slash
function name
now of course when i say user of course
we'll be setting up
a lot of the front end so i'm just
talking about if you directly navigate
from the browser so we go here with
forward slash api
forward slash and then whatever is going
to be the function name and since of
course there's going to be many
functions
we're just going to go with star that
means whatever comes
after the forward slash and where are we
going to be redirecting to
well we already have the path right we
already have that nullify
not functions and then again we just
need to come up with
some kind of wildcard so we just need to
supply it
in our two value so i'm going to
navigate back to notify tom
we go with forward slash matlify
not the five forward slash functions
and then if i want to match the star
i just need to go with forward slash
colon
and splat so now i'll match whatever
function name
comes after api and i'll redirect to
that nullify functions and splat and
eventually we'll set up the status but
let me just show you why i would want to
do that in the first place
before we go to the browser let me just
emphasize something
where this path will always work
just because we have redirect from the
api doesn't mean that
now this url is invalid now
the dot number five forward slash
functions and then whatever function
name will always work
but we're just making it easier for us
and then for the user as well
where we'll be able to access all our
functions with forward slash api
forward slash and then function name so
let's test it out
i'm going to open up a new tab i'm gonna
go with localhost
and then eight eight eight of course
and then let's try it out i'm gonna go
with forward slash api
and then i'm looking for my first
function so i'm just gonna say
one hello and as you can see we have our
first
middle five function example so i'll
quickly navigate back and remove the
example just so you don't think that i'm
cheating
and there it is now of course we have
our first notify function and
just to showcase that everything still
works i'll also navigate back to the
starter
and remember our first example notice
now of course we don't have that
example as the last word we just have
our first
middle five function and again this is
just to showcase that
this path that we have that nullify
function
still works so all of that is still
correct
but there's one tiny gotcha
notice how in the url i type dot nullify
functions or i'm sorry i typed forward
slash api
and then function name however now check
out the new value
in the url and the value essentially
is that nullify for slash functions
and then the function name so what's
happening here
well we could use another awesome tool
and that is browser network tab just to
see what is happening
you should select all and we should type
one more time
in the url bar so let me remove and i'm
going to say api and then one hello
and then notice how we have two requests
so we have the first one for the api and
hello
and the status is moved permanently
so status is 301 and then we have
another one to that nullify functions
and then hello and that is happening
because by default
when we set up the redirect in netlify
they'll set up the status of 301
and as a result the url is also going to
change
when we navigate to that resource and we
can clearly see that
over here and as a side note browser
network tab is an awesome
resource for you to find out more about
the requests and responses for example i
can click on the first one
and i'll make this one bigger right now
and as you can see
we can see the url we can see the method
again
by default this is going to be get and
then we have
301 which just says moved permanently
and again this is going to come in handy
later
once our requests get a bit more
complicated
so now what i would want is to navigate
back to middle fight tamu
and like i said provide the last the
third value here
where i'm going to say status is equal
to
200 all right so in this case
we're not going to have this 301 we're
going to have 200
and because of that the url won't change
as well
so let me just showcase that one where
i'm gonna
i think i'm gonna close those headers
here and again back in url bar
for the last time hopefully in this
video i'm going to type
api one hello and then notice how only
we have one request
and that was in 200 and also the
value in the address bar didn't change
as well
that should do it as far as the redirect
now of course we can go back to app.js
i'll keep it for your reference
the network file functions and all that
and we're just going to copy and paste
and we'll change this around to api
and then hello and also in the hello.js
let's add that example just so we can
see that everything still works
we're in our first example once i
refresh notice i get this example which
just means that
both paths at the moment work because we
have
properly set up the redirect and the
last thing that i want to do in this
video
i would want to fix that annoying auto
import
first of all let me show you why is that
happening in the first place
and i'm going to comment both of my
axios
at the moment but i'm going to write
axios and you'll notice that
we are right away importing from
the node modules and the reason why is
that happening is because
later we will use axios package
in our serverless functions when we
communicate to some
third party apis now technically
you can install a different package
maybe node fetch
but i wanted to stick with axios and we
just simply need to
remove the suggest from the visual
studio code
again visual studio code is just trying
to help us
but in this case it's not necessary
because we already have the script for
the axios
in our front end so in order to fix it
we're going to go to the settings
and i believe the setting name was
javascript suggests so we're going to go
with
javascript and then suggest
and the property you're looking for is
javascript
suggest an auto import please make
sure that you uncheck the proper one
otherwise
it's going to be hard to follow along
with a course
so go with javascript suggest and then
auto import
and let me just double check so in the
app.js
if i type axiorys notice now i'm not
getting that import
from the node modules which is awesome
so now of course i'll remove axiorys
just keep in mind that you still have
access
to axiorys library you're just not
getting that auto import
from the node modules so let me remove
this sucker
and uncomment the last one the api hello
because i'll leave this one
for your reference awesome and now we're
ready to move on to our
next example and the last thing that i
would like to mention
in this video is the fact that when you
go online
and look for serverless functions
example in a lot of cases you'll find
the syntax
where there are tabs when we're setting
up
new lines like so and also for the
values
please what i've seen in most cases
they use this double quotation mark
now i have to be honest i haven't run
into any issues without the tabs
and just with a single quotation mark
but just to stay consistent this is what
i'm going to do
i'm just going to set everything up as
double quotation mark again
that is up to you i haven't run into any
issues
with the previous syntax but just
stay consistent i'm just going to
refactor it a bit
beautiful and now let's take a look what
is going to be our
second example and in our second example
i would want to build
a basic api so in here
notice once we navigate to examples
and then second basic api index html
we're going to get some product with
images with price as well as the name
and if you want to see what is happening
on the back end
then in the complete project instead of
navigating
to the examples using the link you can
simply go to
forward slash api and then i believe the
function name was
second basic api so let's try it i'm
going to go with api
2 and then basic
api and there it is now of course this
is what is
served from the function and that's why
on the front end we are able to fetch it
and then just iterate over
our list and then display it on the
screen
now since the word api is probably
the most overviews word in the community
let me just emphasize something in our
case when we talk about
api we are talking about creating a
http interface for interacting
with our data essentially some data but
of course in our case
that is very specific we're talking
about the product data
now if you're in general interested what
is an api
or if you just need to brush up i found
this awesome
article from freecodecamp so
just go to the google and you can simply
type what
is api and then here keep on scrolling
keep on scrolling
again we're looking for free code camp
article
for some reason cannot find it it was on
the first
it was what is api oh there it is yeah
sorry
scrolled past it and this is an awesome
article that pretty much
covers everything in basic terms
so it's very easy to understand so if
you're kind of iffy
what is an api because again this is
probably the most overused
in a community because these days
everything is api
then just please navigate to the article
and i think this is going to give you
a very very good idea what the api is
and
essentially what is the purpose so again
in our case
it's going to be the http interface
for interacting with our data
so we're going to have the front end
that fetches the product
and our goal is to set up the serverless
function
that serves those products now this is
going to be the basic api
so this is going to be using local data
so there's just going to be some array
that we'll just dump
in our servers function but in the next
example
we'll make it more interesting where
essentially
we will get the data from
one of the headless cmss and in our case
we're going to use the air table again
that is the next project for this
project all we have to know that will
create an api
where on the front end we're able to
fetch it and display
nicely on the screen all right so
let's get cracking and what i'm going to
do first
is just close all the tabs so my setup
is cleaner
and then of course i would want to
navigate to
the functions and we'll create that
function
and again in my case i'm going to go
with second and then
basic api just because i'm annoying that
way
and then right away let's restart the
server so that way
we don't have to do that later so in the
functions
new file and i'm gonna zoom in just so
you can see better
and we're gonna go with two and then
basic
api dot js and what i'm gonna do just so
i can see that
everything works i'm just gonna grab
from the first example
copy and paste and i'm just going to say
our basic api
example so that way when we navigate
to the url i know that if i can see the
message of course
everything works and then like i said
every time we create a new function yes
we'll have to run npm
run and then notify
so now let me navigate to the browser i
think i'll close
some of the tabs now there it is this is
my new tab i don't think i need this one
either and this is going to be the
complete one
which for the time being is going to
stay the way it is
but in starter i'm going to navigate
back home
we're going to go to basic api at the
moment there's nothing there
what we're really interested is on a
local host
we want to go to forward slash api
forward slash
basic api and if you can see
our basic api example we are in good
shape
now let me reiterate something where
when we send back the data in the body
it always always needs to be a string
that's how the communication between the
server
and the browser takes place now
of course in our case when we are
sending back array
we would need to do something with it
right otherwise well that is an array
and we're not going to be able to do
that and i already kind of showed you
the example what happens
if we have an array but just to
reiterate let's do it one more time
where i'm going to go with items it's
going to be an array and in this case
it's just gonna be an array
of two objects and we're gonna go here
with
name susan susan
and then the second thing is gonna be
the name of anna
so again another object and the name
will be anna
and if i try to dump it here
of course i'm gonna have a big fat error
and we kind of already covered that
before
where it says your function response
must have a string
body so technically the only thing i
would need to do
is just run json and then the method
name we're looking for
is stringify and now we just need to
pass in
our items array and once we do that
we should be in good shape
so as you can see if i would want to
create a
api where essentially i'm sending
this array with my product data
the only thing i would need to do is in
the basic api
create an array then add all the
properties with the values
and then pass it through the json
stringify
and technically we can definitely do
that here in the basic
api but wouldn't you agree that it would
be nicer
if we could keep our data separate
so that way if there's more
functionality this
file doesn't just get massive wouldn't
you agree that that would be nicer
where essentially i could just keep my
product in a separate place
and that's exactly the approach that i
took that's why if you take a look at
the assets
you'll find this data js and again
we are in nodeland that's why over here
we have the array
yes every product is an object
and then for every object i have the id
i have the name
image and all that but then at the
bottom i have
module dot exports and i'm just
exporting
the items array if you're familiar with
es6
this should ring a bell because of
course
the functionality is exactly the same we
are exporting
the items just the syntax is a little
bit different because
node uses common js so now of course in
the basic api instead of creating
items from the scratch what we can
simply do is go with
items and we can require it
from our assets and in the require
we need to go with the path and then
check it out
so we have our basic api sitting in the
functions
now the data is in the assets folder
so we need to go one level up then look
for the assets
and then we're looking for data so let's
go
one level up we're going to go to assets
and then we simply want to go
with data so now of course we import the
items
and now you'll see that instead of
displaying just name susan and namana
we're going to have all our products and
essentially this is all we have to do
in our services function just grab the
data
run through json stringify and now
you're able to access it in your project
and then build your front end with that
data
awesome and once our local
api matches to what we have
in complete one now let's quickly build
the front end and again i'm gonna
navigate to complete project
in fact i'll set them side by side so
maybe the first one or the second one is
going to be
where i'll showcase the responses from
the functions
and then i guess in the first step i'm
just going to show you
what is going to be the end result so
here we have the basic api and then we
simply want to
grab data iterate over and just display
something on the screen
again please don't worry we're not going
to spend too much time on that because
this is a separate issue if you're using
a different front end of course
the setup is going to be different for
you i just want to showcase how that
would work so you don't say hey
you showed me the function but you
didn't show me how to consume it
and i know i said this before but the
reason why we're using the
vanilla approach basically where i use
the vanilla js and then
html and css because that way i can
showcase that the functionality
will work with any framework
so i'm going to navigate back to our
project i think i'll
close everything that i have currently
open
and we're going for examples we're going
for
basic api again let me zoom in
if you cannot see it and then as far as
the index
html and as a side note there's global
css here
logo and style css and i purposely added
these things here
because there is a gotcha and i'll cover
that a little bit later
so please don't worry i'll talk about
why we have these extra files and what
is happening
for now just understand that that is not
a glitch
it is purposely here and in the
index.html
and i think this is going to be the case
where i'll have to zoom out i have of
course the
title i have global styles i have style
css all that is good
of course i have the logo i also have
here
a comments and this is designed for
people who don't want to type
the response that we're going to be
typing and again you'll see
why we have that in a second and then of
course we have basic api
and for time being we just have the
loading so if i
navigate in localhost to examples and
then to basic
index.html of course this is what i
should see
and we already know that we can access
the array of course
so now in the app js what i would want
is
to grab that array and then just iterate
over and then for every item i want to
return
the product all right so let's go to
app.js i already selected the result
like i said
i'm going to be adding some code just so
we don't have to
retype the same boilerplate code
every time we set up the example and
then
once i have access to the result to
my node then i would want to come up
with a function
and the function name will be fetch data
so we're going to go here with const
fetch fetch and data
that's going to be my function again
it's going to be async
since we're going to be waiting for the
asynchronous response
and then we'll right away invoke it as
well so we're going to go with
fetch data and then let's just start
with simple console log
second example
so let's console log that one and if you
can see the second example in the
console
by the way this one probably i can make
it smaller should be in good shape
there it is now i have the second
example so now of course
we're looking for the data that is
coming back
from our serverless function correct
and since i'll set up the white i'll
right away
add the try and catch block and like i
said i'll write away the structure the
date out
because essentially that's what we're
looking for and then again we go with
await
then we're going with axiorys and by the
way shouldn't be a dot there
axios again get request and then
what is the url forward slash api
unless you have a different name of
course and then two
and then basic and of course
api and for time being i'll simply go
with
result result and then inner html
and i'll set up the heading 2 here where
i'm going to say
the request was successful or
success something along those lines
something really
nice and simple and neat
so let's go here with heading two
and let's just type success since
there's gonna be a different return
in a second anyway so we're gonna go
with heading two and then if there is an
error
i'll simply say there was an error
on error please try again later please
try again later now
if i didn't cover that at the moment
we're gonna have
the loading because that is in the
result but then
once we're done fetching data either
we're gonna have the product which of
course we haven't set up yet
or we're gonna have that error so let's
save this one
and then once we refresh of course we
have the success because everything went
well but
if we just test it out and if we go back
to
our functions and then basic api and if
i'll change this one
to 404 what do you think i'm going to
have on a screen
of course there was an error please try
again
later and i think i'm not going to go
with heading
4 or 2. in fact i'm going to go with
heading 4 because i think it's going to
be a bit smaller
so let's try one more time and there it
is there was an error
please try again later so that is
happening
if we have the error and yes there's
going to be an error
in a specific situation that we haven't
covered yet
and we'll do that in later videos don't
worry so we're going to go with basic
api
i'll set it back to 200 because of
course now i want to deal
if the response was successful and for
time being let's just look at the data
and of course we already know that
we should have the array correct so we
have array of four items
and in the html with vanilla.js
essentially what i would want is to
iterate over my
array and then wrap
each product in some kind of html and
just supply that
dynamic data and of course i can do it
directly here i can
go with the result in our html that is
definitely an option but
i'll add this extra step because in my
opinion
it's just a bit explicit what we're
doing
so we're going to go with const products
and that is going to be
equal to data and now i'm mapping over
my array and then of course i can access
every item here
in a parameter and i'm just going to
call this product
and for time being if you want to
console log the product
you can definitely do so so we can go
with product and then you'll see that
again each product is that object
and then in the object i have these
properties so what i would want to do
is access each and every property and
then
wrap that property in the html
so for example for the image i would
want to place this
url in the source of the image stack
hopefully that makes sense and what i
would want to do first
is the structure those properties out of
this
product so i'll set this equal to my
product
to my parameter and as far as the
structuring
we are gonna say image and now image is
an
object i purposely set that up because
this is something that we're gonna get
when we're working with airtable which
is gonna be our next example
just to make it interesting so we're to
go here with url
then we're looking for the price and the
name so these are the three things
that we're looking for and as far as the
return well
this is where i would want to return
that html right
now i would want to dynamically add
these properties though
because we need to understand that for
every product
of course these values are unique but
my html structure of course is going to
be exactly the same for all of them
so we go here with return and if you
don't want to
type you simply go back to the
index.html and this is why i added
these comments so what you can simply do
is copy and then in the app.js
in the template string and copy and
paste
now maybe wait a minute so let's see we
have the comment here
you know what you need to uncomment
first my apologies so
uncomment this first then copy and then
in the app.js and sorry for the detour
copy and paste so now you're returning
this article
and now of course since we have this in
a template string
i can access these values now i'll
retype it from the scratch
just so i can go over what we're doing
but again if you're just lazy on typing
or if you maybe get some kind of error
you can always
reference this one so let me just
comment this one out
in my case but in your case
if you want to speed this along then of
course you can copy and paste
so for every item i would want to return
a
article so that's going to be my tag
then class
and we'll pass in the product so that's
going to be
my main return and inside of this
article we'll
set up a few more html tags we'll start
with
our image so in here we go with image
and again
since we're using the template literal
i can simply access those values the
ones that i destructured
from my product so here i can say yeah
for the image i would want to grab the
url and also for the alternative i'm
just going to grab
my name so we're going to go here and
we're going to access the name
now close the image then i would want to
set up a div with the info so
div with the class of info and the
reason why we're adding those classes
because of course
in the css in the local css you'll find
the styling for these items
so let's close the div as well and then
inside of this div
we're just gonna go with a heading five
heading five and here of course i'm
looking for the name
so let me close my tag first
and then dynamically we'll access our
name property
and then you can probably already guess
that we since we have the price
there's also going to be a price so i'll
copy and paste this
heading 5 and we'll add a class
of price just for styling purposes
and let's add here a dollar sign and
then instead of accessing the name
we're going to go with price now this is
going to
still return a array but in order to
showcase it we need to turn it into the
string
so what we could do is just chain join
method
and since i wouldn't want the commas in
between the items
i'm just going to say join them with an
empty space let's save this
and here i can probably make it one line
less
and now instead of the success
what we had previously simply type
product and then once we navigate
to our front end we should have the
product and that's it
within a matter of minutes we have
ourselves a working api
where we have some kind of data we dump
it
in service function and then we pass it
through the json stringify of course
and then we can connect it to our front
end
iterate over our data and we have
ourselves a
beautiful application awesome beautiful
we're done with our first two examples
and normally we would deploy this
project
only at the very end at least that's
what i normally do
in rest of my courses however in this
case we'll make an exception
and here's why essentially there's three
reasons first
i believe that one of the biggest
reasons why you took this course
is because you wanted to set up the api
that you can consume
in your own project second we still have
a course bug
that we will tackle along the way
and three we'll take a look at how nice
is continuous deployment with netify
now in order to follow along you will
need two things
you'll definitely need a netify account
if you haven't created one
and you'll also need a github account
so if you don't have these accounts
please set them up
i'm not going to show you how because
this is somewhat of
a advanced course so i believe that you
already have both of these things
but if you don't please set up these
accounts and then follow along
with the rest of the videos all right
and i'm going to start by creating a
new github repo of course name is up to
you but
since i'm going to be deleting this repo
my convention
is to call this temporary and that way
if i later find this repo then i know
that i can just delete it
so i'm going to go temporary and then
server
less func so that's going to stand
the name for my repo and essentially
we're looking for
these three commands because if you
remember the very beginning of the
course
we did set up already a new repo
we ran git init so let me just copy
these commands
and while we're still on a topic you
know what i'll also
change the name here i'll say serverless
functions
and i'll just remove that starter so now
let's navigate
back to our project we want to open up
of course the terminal
and i would want to stop the server here
so we already have initialized the git
repo of course
that is already out of the way now what
i would want is to run
git add so now i'll add this one
to the staging area and then we'll say
git
commit and as far as the message
i'm gonna say testing deploy
as always these messages are up to you
and then we just want to copy and paste
and if everything is correct and as i
said we're copying pasting
those three commands that we copied
from the github and if everything is
correct we
should see our project awesome
and next we would want to navigate to
netlify
we go to our dashboard of course and
essentially there's
few ways how we can get the project
up and running there is drag and drop
option however
i want to show you right away the
continuous deployment because in my
opinion
it's just going to make more sense in
the long run anyway
so we need to go here with new site from
git
and then of course we're choosing the
get a provider
and then if that's the first time
they'll probably ask you to authorize
and then again in my case i'm looking
for temporary
you need to look for your name and then
once we get to repo i'm gonna go with
temporary
serverless functions now later
we'll take a look at how to work with
env variables
and just as a side note we don't have
the variables yet but
for example for your own projects if you
want to add them right away you just
need to click
on these advanced settings and this is
where you add the variables now don't
worry
just because we're adding them later
we're not going to do that right now
and in fact we'll use the dashboard
to add them so don't stress about it i'm
just showing you
that as a side note and we'll just
keep all of these the way they are we
need to change anything
and we just go with deploy now as far as
the interface
i would probably want to change the name
so i'm going to go to site
settings and we need to click on
change site name and of course if the
name is already taken
and you won't be able to do that but in
my case i'm gonna go
with temp server less
and then func which of course stands for
functions
we save it it's awesome the name is not
taken
it looks like everything went correct
now
if there are some issues you can always
check in your deploys
like so so for example notice this was
our deploy
and then i can check if everything went
correct if not then of course
there's going to be a error message and
i can nicely see that i have
two functions i have the hello and i
have the basic
api now let me navigate back
to my project the
temp server list functions and i'll show
you that later anyway but
just as a side note if you want to add
environment variables which we're going
to use later
you go to domain settings
and you look for build and deploy and
keep on scrolling
and notice here we have environment
variables
just like we had in the advanced
settings so those are the two places
where you would add those variables
either
when you deploy the project or later if
you forgot
or if you added some extra ones then of
course you can just go here to build and
deploy and then
look for environment variables and again
i know i'm skipping a little bit ahead
but
this is just a side note in case you
ever wonder how to add those
environment variables and now of course
we can check
our functions under the functions tab as
well notice i have two
functions here awesome now
what i really would want is probably to
take a look at the usage
so let's see here functions level and
then notice how at the moment
my requests are 0 out of 125 thousand
so like i said they give you a pretty
generous tier
but then once we talk about the error
table i'm gonna kind of give you
an idea of why you should be always
careful
of how you're setting up the api now the
last thing that i would want to showcase
is that even though our project works
nicely and by the way in order to
navigate there
we just click on the site overview or
the link that they
previously provided and that's it we
just navigate here notice
this is a live site and then of course
we can take a look at
one of the projects we have built
already and i think in my case i'm going
to go with basic api
and there it is we have our api
up and running and also let's test out
the first one
and in here i should have the text so
let me inspect
and in the console i can see that app.js
is having some kind of issues so let me
go back to my project
and let me check my first function so
have
hello here now this sends 200 and
everything should be working fine
but in the examples there's some kind of
issue so let me go back to app.js
as you can see i have both of them
commented out
that's number one and that's why if i'm
trying to access this data of course
it is not going to work so as a side
note i'm also going to cancel log
the error response and this is the cool
thing about the continuous deployment
that we
just set up with netlify and
github so the way it works if you want
to change
something you just change it locally and
here i can clearly see that
there has been some changes so now of
course
what i would want is push this back up
to the github
and in this case i'm going to use the
visual studio code
gui for that now definitely of course
you can
set it up using the integrated terminal
again you would run git add git commit
and then you would push it
but i find this much easier where
essentially i just need to type the
message
and i'm going to say fixed first
function or example i guess and then
i'll say yep i'm going to agree always
and then we'll just push it up and say
push
and now of course we're pushing this up
to the github now let me zoom out
and we should see that there has been
some changes
fixed first example and also if we take
a look at
the netlify now check it out we have
another deploy already scheduled
so we're building our new project
so every time we'll be pushing this up
to the github network is smart enough
it has hooks where it's getting notified
that hey listen
there has been some changes to the repo
so please
rebuild the site so now of course what i
could do is go back to my project
and just double check now of course i
have tons of tabs open here
so let's see we're waiting waiting
waiting waiting waiting
everything should work well hopefully it
does at least so i don't have to
go back and fix the errors we have the
star of course
and for some reason i don't know it
takes ages and then if i check out the
hello world now i should see our first
metalfi function example so that's the
basic setup
for the nettlefi and github
where we can set up continuous
deployment so that way
if there's ever some changes to your
project
you just add them locally then push it
up to the github
and then notify smart enough to
rebuild your project uh next video
we'll talk about the course errors that
we still
get from our serverless functions
awesome we deployed our project
everything works smoothly but
there's one tiny issue yes we can
access our serverless functions nicely
from our application
and we can clearly see that once i fixed
my bugs everything works we're getting
the data
and we're in good shape but you probably
would want to
set up your project where you could
fetch that data
from different applications so basically
from the applications that are not in
your server and at the moment
we won't be able to do that now
in order to showcase that first of all i
would want to navigate
to my second function so i'm going to go
with
api and then remember the name was 2
hyphen and i believe it was basic api
basic api and i can see that when i'm
using the browser
i'm able to access the product but the
problem is
if i have the application that i would
want to access
those resources and that's why i would
want you to go back
to your project and then
in the examples look for the second one
for the basic one
and i would want you to copy the whole
folder again
technically if you don't want to do that
you don't have to you can just
sit back relax and watch but if you want
to test it out yourself
then just grab this folder now i
wouldn't suggest drag and dropping
because again you'll mess up the whole
structure but just copy the folder
and make sure that you copy outside of
the
server so i'm going to do it on my
desktop
so there's my basic api now what i would
want
is to open up a new window in my text
editor
then drag and drop and i would simply
want to change
the path so at the moment we're using
this forward slash api
to basic and of course everything works
because
previously our project was on the same
server
however it's not going to be the case
anymore so now of course i
want to go back and i would want to get
this url
so i'll copy and paste and technically
nothing should change correct why well
because it's the same resource
we just saw that we still serving the
same product
well okay let's save it and now i'll
just open this
up using the browser so go to index.html
and as a side note
that's why i add these global css is and
logos and everything so
project can work on its own so it
doesn't have to be
in the examples folder or in the starter
so let me spin this up index.html
and there it is i right away have this
there was an error please
try again later and if we inspect
we should see the course error where
essentially we are getting a message
that we cannot access this resource
if the project or application or
whatever
is not on same server and the reason why
is that happening well because
remember we are of course in charge
right
so let me minimize this and since we are
in charge
we didn't specifically say that hey
listen it's okay
for different applications to access
this resource
that's why if you deploy the project
and if you're expecting this to be
accessible
on different apps that maybe are
deployed also on netfly
or whatever you won't be able to do that
now
it's an easy fix where we need to go
back to
basic api that's our function
and we just need to add headers so again
when we're communicating there's
multiple things there's status codes
there's http methods and there's also
headers
that we're sending so in here we need to
go with headers
that's the property name and then inside
of the object
we need to set up the property and we go
with axis
and again make sure that you use the
same
syntax otherwise it's not going to work
so ctrl
allow allow and then we go
origin and we need to set this equal to
the star so we go here with a star
so again we made some changes to the
project so since we're using this
continuous deployment the only thing we
need to do
is just set up the message and i'll say
course error fixed
and we'll send this up to the get up
so say push and we're going to be in
good shape
now one thing that i would like to
mention that of course
if you want your resources to be
accessible from different apps
you need to set it up for every function
where you'd want that so in my case i'm
just showing you
with an example for the second function
but keep in mind
that it's not going to automatically
work on the first one
so again if you want that for a function
make sure
that you add the headers and you set up
the property with access control
allow origin and then equal to star now
i'm just going to set it up for the
second one as an example how it works
for a remainder i'm going to skip that
part but if you want
you need to add that for all the
functions
where you would want that data to be
accessible outside
of our current setup and now i think
i talked long enough where we should
have another deploy
so let me refresh again in here nothing
is going to change of course we were
still
able to access the data but now if i go
back
to my basic api we should be in good
shape
where now notice i can access
these products because now of course i
set it up where you can access from the
different app
even that app is not on your server
hopefully it's clear and once we have
deployed the project once we have
fixed our course error now of course we
can work
on our next example where we'll
introduce a nice
graphical interface to set up our data
before we continue let me just reiterate
my own experience
with free requests one more time
you see 125 000 is really generous
and it's definitely going to cover most
of our use cases but when it comes
to api it's a bit tricky
and the story goes something like this
when i was building my react course
i set up my own api just so students can
practice data fetching in react
and of course that way i don't need to
worry about
some api adding some changes and making
that part of the course
out of date now everything was awesome
until i released the course
and discovered that to my surprise i was
getting around
300 000 requests a day well of course
you can upgrade and get more requests
just remember that
every upgrade will cost you more
of your hard earned money and
when it comes to apis what if you end up
getting 1 million requests a day
so instead i opted into setting up an
express server
on digitalocean since the fixed cost
seemed a bit more reasonable so yes
serverless functions on netfly are
awesome
the free tier is extremely generous
and it is going to cover most of your
use cases
but when it comes to api or
some other specific setup just be
mindful
where you might need to go the other
route
where effectively you do set up your own
server
and that way you can manage the cost
better and once we're done setting up
our basic api
now let's take a look at the better
approach you see
wouldn't be nicer if instead of hard
coding this data
locally in our project we would have a
graphical interface and then every time
we add
changes in the graphical interface
our data will be automatically
updated in the project so i'll be able
to show you of course
for you you'll have to set up the air
table which we're going to cover in next
videos
but i'll be able to showcase since i
already have the account
connected to this project so i'm going
gonna navigate to the air table and then
notice how we have
three products over here but what i
could do
is go to my table and don't worry of
course
we'll set up all of this in the upcoming
videos but
i would just want to add that extra
product so i'm going to say t-shirt
i'm going to copy and paste the info i
already downloaded
the photo so i just need to grab it from
the desktop
t-shirt over here and then i just need
to come up with the price
which in my case is going to be
300 i think that
is going to make the most sense once i
navigate back
to my project and i refresh essentially
i invoke the serverless function one
more time
now of course i have my product and i
can navigate to
the single page and in order to
store our data and access it and modify
it
and all that good stuff using graphical
interface
i'm going to use service called airtable
again there's not particularly anything
special about this service
you can definitely use other platforms
and setups as well
the reason why i picked airtable because
it does have
generous free tier and what i also like
is the fact that if you do go the
payment route
then the payments are not enormous for
example for a freelancer i believe
at the time of the recording the account
was for ten dollars a month
and as i know this is something annoys
me a little bit about the headless
seamlesses
where they go from zero which is the
free tier right away to the forty
dollars what i really like about
airtable is the fact that
they have this simple setup where yes
you have generous free tier
but if you do decide to get more
options then the pricing is not
ridiculous
essentially ten dollars a month for
a good setup now that's not the reason
why i picked the air table of course
again they have the
free tier and of course we'll use it the
reason why i picked air table because
it is very easy to get up and running
with airtable
we are literally talking about the rows
and columns i mean what can be easier
than that
and also even though most of the things
i like about airtable
there's actually one downside and that
downside is the fact that
in airtable in order to access data
in any way you would need to
send your request with your api key
now the problem with that is that the
moment
somebody gets a hold of your api key
he or she can wipe out your whole data
so the problem is that there is no
public api
it's not like i can just set up data and
say hey listen this is what i would want
to share
with the rest of the world and this is
for example
only for me so i would only want to
delete edit or whatever no that's not
how it works with airtable
however with serverless functions we can
use it to our advantage
because normally i definitely wouldn't
suggest
using airtable directly on your front
end
because keep in mind even though you set
this up as environment variable
for example in react app it's still
accessible
people can still see that if they go
through your source code
so we'll use that to our advantage which
is technically a downside
for the air table because you cannot
stick
the request directly in your front end
but what we could do is set up a service
function
that fetches the data from their table
and then we hide those environment keys
and of course
as we're working through the examples
it's going to make
way more sense if you're iffy about
something at the moment
again if you don't like the air table
you can just take a look at the examples
and use your own backend whatever you're
using whether that's contentful
whether that is strappy or whatever
so in the next video of course we'll
sign up for a
free airtable account and once we're
done discussing
why i picked airtable in order to
store our data now let's sign up
for free together and i'm just going to
use one of my dummy accounts
and i believe the email was learn code
tutorial
at gmail.com so i'm going to go as peter
smith now the email is going to be learn
code tutorial
gmail.com and then let's create
an extremely extremely hard password to
crack
so let's go here that is going to be my
password
and i'm just going to go with sign up
for free
once we sign up i'm not going to save
this password
we are given an option to free trial of
airtable pro it's not what i want and
then
it says well tell us about about
yourself
well we want to do i guess build and
launch the product whatever
something like that and then notice we
need to confirm the
account do you plan to move data no i
don't
continue and then i'll skip this part we
don't need collaborators
but probably it would be better
if we would confirm the email so let's
navigate here
we should confirm the email and then
we're getting
this workspace we're getting my
first workspace and then in the
workspace
we have bases which serve as tables
and like i already previously mentioned
if you have ever done
any work with excel or even
just with tables you should be in good
shape or even if you haven't done work
trust me it's very easy to get started
and we have workspaces and we have the
basis
now at the time of this recording the
difference
why you would want to have the workspace
is because if you have
multiple bases if you have multiple
databases
and you have the collaborator so there's
multiple people that are working
if that person has access to the
database if you give
the person access or permission to the
database
you automatically give the person
access to rest of the basis
on the workspace so for example
i'm just going to rename it i'm going to
say server
less and then imagine that if i create
multiple
databases and i give access to the
person to one of them
then of course he or she automatically
has access to all of them
so that's why you need to be careful if
you know that there's going to be
collaborator
if you know that you'll be giving some
external permissions
to access it it's a better idea to set
up a new workspace
and in that way you can control who can
access the database and in order to set
up the database we simply go with
add a base like so and we can go with
start with template we can import data
or we can simply go with
start from scratch so in my case of
course i'm gonna go with
start from scratch then we need to come
up
with a name i think i'm gonna go with
tutorial like so we can pick the colors
we can pick the icons
whatever you would want and should be in
good shape
once we login we're gonna have this
example and you know what i'm gonna
stick
with views so i'm gonna remove this one
and that way i have a little bit more
room and then
i also am a bit annoying with these
names
i don't like to have them as a
capitalized ones so instead what i'm
going to do is i'm going to say
that the first table name will be
products and i always like to use the
lowercase
again don't ask me why that is just my
preference and the same
goes with a column name so notice here
of course
we have the columns and then here we
have the rows
now one interesting thing that i must
warn you about the error table is the
fact that even though you have these
rows as
empty when you're fetching data they
actually come
back as a actual data
if that makes any sense so for example
if you have 15 items and then you have
three of them empty
you would think that they're not being
sent when in fact they are
so that's why you need to be careful
where every time
you add something to the air table make
sure that there's no
empty rows because as you can imagine
there's some kind of functionality that
we're doing
on our back end when we're fetching from
the air table correct uh if for example
i'm iterating over data and if i'm
trying to
access some properties and they don't
exist well
your app might break that's one of those
hard bugs to catch because
essentially it's just a innocent
empty line that should do it for the
general setup
and next video we'll start setting up
the columns
and adding the values as well awesome
once we have the airtable account once
we create a new base
and we set up a new table by the name of
product
then of course i would want to add the
data
and let's see what we would want so
i'm going to navigate back to complete
project i'm looking for the h
table and essentially it's going to be
the same thing where we have some kind
of image
we have of course the name as well as
the price
and also since we'll make this project a
bit interesting
we'll also add the description
now please keep in mind one thing where
i purposely kept this info
as little as possible because i just
don't want to spend too much time
on data entry now what i would like you
to show you
is the fact that of course you can go as
complicated
as you would want so for example if you
have
enrolled in my react course you know
that we have the
e-commerce store and for the e-commerce
store
i did set up the data in the air table
and you can notice that you can set it
up as complicated
as you would want again the reason why
we're not going to do that
in this project because it's just going
to take too much time
and i think it's somewhat unnecessary
but just don't think that you can add
only simple data
you can make it as complicated as you
would want
so let me close this one and i'll keep
another one for reference so this is the
one that i was
setting up for this tutorial so i
want to have a name i would want to have
description column
image column as well as the price column
and as you can see
i like to keep all my names lowercase
because
that just avoids some unnecessary bugs
again this gives me that grid view which
i don't want and i want to rename this
one i'm going to go with
name now this is going to be a simple
text
so when you click on the column
you can set it up the data type
essentially and here you can have single
text long text
and of course you can see the other
options so in this case we're going to
go with
single text now i believe the next one
is description that i have so let me
have it as description i'll keep that
one
as a long text because here we'll just
grab some
value for description and i always like
to go
with not lorem ipsum hipster epsom and
the website is hypsum
so i'll say beer me and i'll grab
this value whatever you would want
doesn't really matter
just add some kind of text and now i'm
going to navigate
back to the air table and we'll just
copy and paste
so for all of them it's going to be
exactly the same now for the attachments
i'll rename this one
and you know what by the way let me show
you how you would delete the column as
well
so right click it delete the column and
i'll delete both of them and then if you
want to create a new one
of course press on a plus and then the
name i went with
was image and then like i said you have
multiple data types and the one that
we're looking for
should be i believe attachment yeah
that's the one
so we create that and asked me to import
data no i don't want to do that
and then the last one will be the price
let's see here i named this price and
then
for the data type normally you would
probably go with number
and i'll talk about it when we work with
stripe but in here i just went with
currency
and i went with dollar and the precision
yeah
i'll just leave it the way it is so we
create a field
that is all good as far as the name
again
sorry but i'm going to be going back to
see what i have
so blue and then sneakers
sneakers as far as the image this is
where you would want to go
to the assets that we have in a star
so click on select files now there's
multiple options you can get it
online and all that but what you're
looking for is the desktop
server list functions and then in the
assets you have
for the three products product one
product two and
product number three we open this up we
upload of course the product and then we
just need to come up with a price
which in my case is going to be 39.99
something like that and once we're done
we just need to add the other two
as well so here this is nike shoes and
pink shoes
so i'm gonna go with nike shoes
and pink shoes description is gonna be
for all of them exactly the same
like so and then for images
we're gonna go with product number two
upload yep and then we're gonna do the
same thing
for product number three again keep in
mind that
this will throw an error since we have
the fourth one empty so that's why i'll
go with right click
and we'll just delete the record so
again we'll add one more image
we're gonna go here with product number
three okay awesome
good we are in awesome shape
and let's just come up with some dummy
values so again
since these are nike shoes i think i'm
going to go with 299
and then for the pink ones we'll go
crazy
and i'll say that it's going to be
thousand dollars
once we're done with that now of course
we need to take a look
how we can consume the data coming from
the air table
nice we have our products in place and
now of course
we would want to know how we can consume
the data
from the api from the error table api
and in order to understand that we need
to go to api documentation so
we just click on this question mark and
then we're looking for api
documentation now their docs are really
really good
they honestly explain everything in
detail but
i have a big issue with their sdk
so first i'll show you how their sdk
would work
and then i'll show you why we would want
to use
the airtable node package that
effectively is built on top of it and
the way it works like i already
previously mentioned with
air table api we need to have the
base id and we'll also need to have the
authentication
and this is where we want to provide our
own api key
all right now why is that very very
important
well it is important because you don't
want to stick
this code in your front
and as a side note you know what i think
i didn't sign up for the key
my apologies let's just quickly go back
to the error table
and i think we need to go to account
actually what i would want is generate
api key
so i'm going to go here and now we're
generating the key
and this is very very important because
we'll have to use that api key
when we're setting up the consumption
when we're setting up the fetch
and that's why you don't want to just
directly go
to your front end for example here and
just add that data
because then anyone who knows how to go
to devtools
can have access to the key and then you
can literally do
anything you would want with that key
for example
you can just remove your whole data and
now of course there is now we have this
show api key again this is dummy account
i have no
problem showing that key because by the
time you're watching this
it's going to be deleted anyway just
keep in mind that when you work
with your own airtable data be
very very careful of how you're sharing
this key because
literally the moment anyone has access
to the key
they can wipe out your whole data like i
said
they have really really nice docs will
have to have
access to the id of the base
this is going to be very important and
we'll also need to have access to
the api key and then when it comes to
their docs they explain
two options we can use for example just
a
regular fetch request again that's
something that we would do
for example from the front end but again
i wouldn't suggest doing that
and also they have this javascript sdk
and overall the javascript sdk that they
provide
is pretty decent now the problem
is for example if you want to list the
records right
so you would need to require it yeah
that's easy
and once we require airtable then we
need to set up a new instance
and we need to provide these two values
we need to provide the api
key and we need to provide the
base id now like i previously mentioned
the base id is right over here and we
can also see the
api key now they're good enough that
they
provide in documentation so for example
if i'm looking at
list records option notice how they
right away supply these values
of course we'll have to set up the
environment variables because you don't
want to
share them in your source code
and then we need to set up the base
where we provide a product
now all of this is nice but then we need
to start
dealing with each page and then fetching
the next page
that's why we'll use another package
that is built on top of it again
yes you can definitely use their sdk but
i think it's just going to be faster if
we go with this package and the name of
the package
is airtable and no
then let's just type npm and then we're
not looking for the air table npm we're
looking for
airtable hyphen node npm
that's the one that we would want now
it's not the most popular package in the
world but
it gets the job done where in this case
we require
our table node we still need to supply
the same values this would be the api
key
and we have the base and then we have
the table
so again in our case what is the
structure
well let me go back here we have
the api key which we just created
then we have the base id which we can
find of course
in our docs right and then as far
as the table well it is product
so make sure that you have all these
values
and then the api is just easier for this
package
where essentially instead of setting up
this next page
and then fetch your next record or
whatever i simply can go with
air table list and then i can just
wait since this returns a promise and
i can just get all my records and you'll
see how much
easier it is to work with this package
and that was the whole point
why we're going to use this package
instead of
their official sdk so for example if i
want to update
again i just create a new instance and i
get the id
and then i can just use the update
method
that's all that's all we have to do and
knowing this
of course we can navigate back to our
project since i already
installed the package and we can start
setting up our serverless function that
fetches the records from the airtable
api
at this point we should have the data in
our table
we should be at least a little bit
familiar
with their api where we need to have the
base id
we need to have the api key as well as
the name
of the table and also we
at least understand the basics of why i
would want to use the airtable node
the package that is built on airtable
because it has a
easier api and since i don't want 10 000
tabs open i'll close the
hipster ipsum and eventually i'll also
close the
api docs for the airtable because we
literally just need
the id of the base as well as the api
key because
rest of the functionality is going to
come from air table
node now i'll repeat probably this
20 times during this video but do not
push the project up to the github
before we set up the environment
variables which we're going to do
in the next video just don't do it again
otherwise you're just sharing with the
rest of the world
your api keys and then whoever gets a
hold of them
can just wipe out your data so we'll
start simple
we'll set up our server list function
without the environment variables and
then later
we will add them and we're going to
start by going to the functions we'll
create
a new one and in this case i'll call
this one
air table our table js
and we'll do the same thing
like we previously did with basic api
where i'm just going to grab the hello
one
and i want to see whether i'm getting
some kind of response
so 200 and i'll call this air table
example
so air table example remember
we needed to restart the server so we're
going to go with npm run
metal file here and then once we spin
everything up
we should have a new tab again we don't
care about the new tab we just want to
go back to our starter
i'm going to refresh it and i'm not
going to be looking
for the second function because now i
would want to get the third one
so let's go with api three
and then the function name was airtable
at the moment
i'm getting the fact that i cannot
access it
that's interesting why is that happening
well that is because i have localhost
3000 for some reason
my apologies i'm going to go back to 888
and if you see the air table example
then we're in good shape and of course
we can continue
and now we want to go back to docks of
the air table node
we would need to install the package
which is
already installed then we require it
and then we set up a new instance and
then we provide these three values api
key base
and table name so let me just grab these
first three lines of code copy and paste
and this is the first time where i'm
reminding you please do not push this up
to the github
in next video set up environment
variables
and we have our table node awesome then
i would want to navigate back to
the airtable docs and i'm looking for
the base
id so pass it here
and i'm looking for my api key so i'll
keep on scrolling keep on scrolling
and then there it is so that is my api
key
of course you can also access it in the
place where we created
and now pass in the api key okay awesome
and then as far as the table what we're
looking for
is the product i believe right so that
was the name
table name we're gonna go with product
and then inside of this handler
i would just want to see what i'm
getting back
so i should have access to this table
to the products and once we have
access to the products table
then in order to access the values again
let's just go back to the airtable node
documentation
we can simply see that we need air table
so that's going to be our instance our
product
table instance and then if i want to get
the records
i just go with list and then
in order to get the actual records we go
by the structuring the records so since
we'll be using again
async await i'll right away set up
try catch now for time being i'll just
leave this return
here the way it is eventually we'll move
it and we'll set up one for error and
one for success
but not for now we're gonna go with cons
and for time being i'll just call this
data
and then again we run await and then our
instance
our air table and then the method name
was
list and i just want to cancel log data
and now keep in mind though
now this data will be in a terminal
not in the browser but we do need to
invoke it so that's why
we'll navigate to our serverless
function
we'll invoke it we'll perform a get
request there it is
and now as you can see in the
console we get back our records
again i know i said this before but you
can
use the airtable sdk it's just going to
be
a bit more painful in my opinion because
you have to jump through some hoops
where airtable node just gives you a
nice api
you want to get the records just run
list and you are in good shape
so here like i said we have the object
the property name is records
and then here i have my array
so in order to get my array i'll simply
say that i would wanna
the structure the records and then
i'm gonna iterate over them and
since the fields is an object itself
and this is where i have my values so
notice here i have the id
i have the fields property and the
fields is an object
now that object represents
all my values it has name description
image
and price and the way we can see that
is by removing this data and we're going
to say cons
product is equal to records and i'm just
going to map
over it because what i would want is to
return
a different structure so i'm going to
call this product so now i'm iterating
over this object and i'm just going to
destructure
a few things from this object and first
i would want to grab the id
now the id of course is sitting in the
product
it is sitting in the object that's why
i'll say id
is equal to the product now rest of the
properties
are going to be sitting in this fields
object if you want you can cancel log it
but in my
case i already know that they're going
to be there so i'm going to go with
name image and price
again why do i know that the names are
like that well because i named them
name description image and price and
we're purposely not looking for
description
because if you take a look at our
project you can see that we're not going
to be displaying the description first
we only want to access that value once
we
open up the individual page for a
product
and don't worry we're going to get there
together so that's why we're not the
structuring description
and we'll set it equal to product
and then fields of course and
once we're done with that i also would
want to get the url
and in order to get the actual url
we would need to grab the first
item in the image array and then
grab the url property again i'm not
going to cancel log it just to speed it
up but
trust me it's there so we're going to go
with url and that is equal to
image and then it is an array and then
we're looking for the first item that's
why we go
with image zero and then more
specifically we're looking for the url
and then from my map method
i would want to return id i would want
to return
name and then url and price
so that's going to be my new object that
i'm returning and i'm just using the
es6 feature where if the names match
then
i can just skip setting the property
equal
to the value so that should be in my
product so now of course
i can cut this sucker out and then
place in my try block then this is going
to be 200 of course
then we go with json string of i
and we pass in the product like so
and then as far as the error yep there's
gonna be a return
and we're just gonna go with 500 and
we'll just say
general server error so server and we're
going to call this error
so once we navigate back to our browser
we fetch and there it is now of course
we have the product
and cool thing of course right now is
the fact that
we are getting these products from the r
table
so now of course nothing stops me from
going back to the air table
and adding an extra product so i'm gonna
go with extra product
then we'll right away copy and paste
everything i'll use the same
image just to speed it up so i'm going
to go with
image number one i'm going to upload
and then we're looking for some kind of
price now i don't want to add that extra
one so
make sure that we delete that one if by
mistake you also add that one
and i'm going to set up the price to be
9.99
and once you have the message that the
data has been saved
you can go back to our serverless
function invoke it one more time
remember that every time we invoke it
and of course we still communicate with
airtable and this is our new data
where we have that extra product and now
of course we just need to go to our
front end
and build a nice user interface
using our data before we set up our
front end though
let me repeat we would always want to
hide
these values we would always want to
keep them
as secret and that's why again we
wouldn't set up the whole functionality
on our front end
because it would be very easy for
somebody to get that data
and even though right now this code
is on our server so technically
no one would be able to go there and
look at the code
the problem is that of course we'll be
pushing this up to the github
and once we do again we're exposing that
there so how we can
set this up as some kind of secret
variables
well in node we have something called
env
variables and the way we set them up
again in the root
that is extremely important we go with
new file
and then we go with dot and then envy
so now of course we're setting up the
file
for our environment variables and then
we just set up
the key value pairs we go with whatever
is the name
and then whatever is the value so
base id and of course the table name
i think that can be exposed it doesn't
really matter but
what i would want to hide of course is
the api key
so here i'm going to come up with a name
so i'm going to say airtable
table underscore api key and a
convention
is using the uppercase but again
you can do whatever you would want and
then as far as the colors if you notice
that the color for the key is different
than the color for the value
it's because i'm using this package and
package name
was dot env so that's the one
that makes it happen and as far as the
value
well i simply would want to probably
close my sidebar and then i'm going to
go to
airtable.js and i'm just going to grab
my api key
so i'll cut it out copy and paste
and now what i would want is of course
to save the file
now keep in mind one thing where in the
git ignored
i purposely add right away dot env
because if you'll not add this to the
getting or again everything that we're
doing is somewhat useless since
everyone will be able to see the env
file anyway
now in the airtable.js in our serverless
function
now of course i would want to access
that variable however it's not as simple
it's not as just going and saying what
is the variable name
that's why we need to use another
package that i have installed
and the package name is dot env
and the syntax is following where we
could technically assign it to some kind
of variable
but we don't have to we simply go with
require
so we require the package name and then
the package name is dot
envy like i said and then we run config
method
and if we have env file in the root then
we don't need to even provide
any kind of parameters to the config we
just
run the config and now of course where
we have the
api key instead of providing the key
and then pushing this up to the github
so everybody can see
i'm going to go with process.env so now
i'm accessing those environment
variables
and then whatever is the name of the
key so in my case it is airtable api key
we go back
we copy and paste and of course we'll
have access to it here
now every time you work with env
variables it
is safer if you just restart otherwise
you will have some weird bug so i'll
stop the server and
run npm run and then
nutlify and by the way i didn't save the
file so
maybe i'm going to have the error cell
stop and restart one more time so npm
run metlify
so we spin this up and
if i go to the forward slash api
and then two or no sorry three
airtable i should have access to my data
so if you still see the data you are in
good shape
that means that everything works and
then once we're done with the project
i'll show you how we would need to set
up
those variables on netfly because now we
need to understand that
the moment we'll push this up to the
github of course
netfly will redeploy our site but
there's going to be an issue
because netflix will complain hey i
don't know what is the value here
so that's why i just wait till we build
out the front end
and then once we're done with that then
we'll push this up to the github
and then i'll show you how to set up the
env variables
on metal files so that way of course
your project
will have no bugs or issues
and once we have added our env variables
now we're in good shape and of course
now we can
continue working on our front end now
since i have a bunch of tabs open i'll
just start
closing them i'll still leave the er
table because later we'll add
a table with more data so that one will
stay however the
api documentation i don't need anymore
since we'll use this one
here instead so keep this one open and
then
this is going to be our complete project
again what we're trying to achieve
is the same thing like in the previous
project where we just
iterate over data and then display the
products on the screen
now this project is going to be a bit
more complex
where it will set up a separate page
for more info so notice once i click
on a product i open up a new page so
that one will be
product html and i provide the id
and then once i navigate to that page
then we refetch the data and more
specifically we get
this description that's why purposely we
didn't pass it
when we were setting up the initial
function
and later i'll show you how to combine
everything
in one function again i'm skipping a
little bit ahead just to give you a
general idea of what we're going to be
working on so
now let's navigate back to our starter
we want to go to the air table
and as you can see this is going to be
our third example
i'll close everything that i currently
have open because we're pretty much
done in our serverless function
so let me close everything and of course
i would also want to close
all my files and i'm looking for
airtable one
and i'm looking for app js so that's
where we'll set up
all our functionality now if you're
interested what is in the index.html
again the same thing we have of course
the air table that's going to be our
title we have the css
we have the nav we have the heading 1
and
time we have this loading in the result
and of course the axiorys so now in the
app.js
i'm just selecting the result and we'll
start by fetching the data of course
so i'll close the sidebar here i'll zoom
in
we'll see how that works maybe i'll have
to zoom out again so we'll go with const
and then
fetch product is equal to async again
it's going to be a synchronous function
because we'll use a weight and i'll
right away
get the data so we're going to go with
const and then data
and where we're fetching this from of
course that is from our
serverless function correct so we're
gonna go with axios.get
and then api three
and i believe the name was airtable let
me just double check so
there are no dumb bugs yep the name was
airtable
fetching that and i would want to right
away
stick it in the try and catch because
maybe
there is going to be a error and if
there is an
error i'm just going to go with result
that's the node that i have selected
and we're just going to go with inner
html
let's set up a heading 4 and let's just
say there was
an error like show i'll close my
heading four and then fourth time being
let's just cancel log the data
just so we can see that everything works
now in this case i did not
set up the console log my apologies i
mean the initial one
hopefully everything works though so
we're gonna go with fetch products
and we should see the data so i navigate
to my airtable one to my starter
i refresh i still have the loading
because
if there's no error of course this is
not going to change and in the console
we should have this array so of course
we have
array of four items and now we just need
to repeat the same
steps that we did in a previous example
the difference of course
that we're going to be returning
different html
but the idea is exactly the same again
we iterate over and then for every item
we have a html and that's why i'll speed
this up i'm going to go with const
products again we'll call this data
we're mapping over
each and every item is an object i'll
reference it as
a product we'll destructure it id
url name price
all that is coming from my product and
as far as the return
we'll go with the return i'll set up
template strings
and this is going to be the difference
where i would want to return
a link because again in a complete
project you can see that
once you click on the item you navigate
to that
individual page and if you take a look
at the
project you can see that in the air
table we also have this
product html so this is where we'll do
a little bit more work where once you
click on a product
we will navigate to this product html
and we'll
have to fetch the info about that
specific product
so that's why it's going to be a link to
a product
html page but we'll have to supply
the unique id of the product
and of course that way we'll be able to
make another fetch request from the
product page
hopefully that makes sense so we're
going to go with href
and here like i said we go with product
html
so that is the page in my example
and then i would want to supply the url
parameter or they're also called
query string parameters
and the way we set up we go with
question mark
and then again we use key value pairs
and you can supply as many parameters as
you would want
but in our case we just want to set up
the id
so generally we work something like this
where we go with question mark and then
after the question mark the syntax is
following where we go with key value
pair
so in our case we're going to go with id
and then of course eventually this value
will be dynamic but just to showcase how
that would work
i would go with id and then for example
one
then if i would want to add more query
string parameters
then of course i'm going to go with and
so we're going to go with this ampersand
and then again the name i don't know
that could be a name itself
and then whatever value so in this case
it's going to be john
and if you have been searching the web
you know that
these can get quite long and this is a
very very useful
info that we can use on the front end
as well as on the back end first we'll
use this on the front end
where notice how we're navigating to the
page but now i would want
dynamically pass in that unique id
of the product and since i'm using
template string
i simply need to pass in the id and in a
second you'll see
how all of them are dynamic because of
course
the id is unique and then still within a
link i'm going to go with class
because we would want to add a little
bit of styling and i'll name this
product and i would want to close
my link tag of course like so and then
inside of this link let's just go with
image
so img then we'll have a source
and this is where i'll pass in that url
of course the one that we're getting
from our serverless function
then we'll pass in the alternative and
again we'll pass
in dynamic value we'll say name over
here
and let's close the image and right
below it
again the same deal we're going to go
with div class and pass
in the info and inside of this div
we're going to say that there's going to
be
a name as well as the price
so let's just do it here let's say
heading 5
and we'll close d heading 5 and
dynamically
insert the name of the product as well
as the price
now for the price again we have the same
spiel where we would want to have
a class so that's why i'll copy and
paste
and i'll just add class and we'll call
this price
and here as far as the value let's add a
dollar sign
and then let's just say price remember
we would want to turn this into a string
so that's why we run
join and we would want to join it with
empty space
that's when we'll provide that empty
quotation mark and then
when it comes to result we're just going
to go with result
in our html and then we go
with products of course if you're for
example using react
then you would set up your component you
would probably set up
use effect and then of course you would
fetch the data and then stick it as your
variable
or something like that meaning state
variable and
once we're done with the setup now let's
just go to our front end
so this is going to be my starter let me
refresh
and i should have my products and there
it is
now of course i have them and i can
nicely display them
now again the key here is that they are
links
so once we click on them notice the
browser url
now we navigate to the same example
example number three now the page is
different of course
right so now we have product html and
here we provide this unique id
so we have query string parameter where
we have question mark
and then in this case the value is the
id
and at this point we just see the single
product
there's nothing specific about it why
well because
in the product html this is what i have
i have the single product and we'll use
this structure
to insert the dynamic data
basically i didn't want to build the
whole structure
together with you i already set up the
structure where i have the single
product
i have the article i have the image and
all that we just need to supply that
dynamic data
so when we navigate to that page with
our info complete then of course i'll be
fetching
the info about that specific
product hopefully it is clear where we
set up the air table
we fetch using the air table node
because it has a simpler api
and this is where we can set up all our
products
and now we just need to worry about how
we can fetch that
extra info which in our case is just
going to be a description
about the product in a single page
using the query string parameters
beautiful we have the basics in place so
now let's
worry about the function that would
provide
info about specific product
now first we'll set up separate function
for that
and then later i'll show you how we can
combine it in one function
where basically if we just want to get
data about all the products
we still provide that but then if we add
the
query string parameter then of course
we're fetching data
about that one specific product so i'm
going to navigate
back to my project i will leave the
product html open
i think i can close the app.js for time
being
and i don't think we need the index.html
as well
hopefully it is clear that in the
products html
we display or i'm sorry in the
index.html at the moment we display the
product
products are linked and then
once we click on a product we navigate
to the product html page
and we pass in the id and of course
later on the front end will do something
with an id because we'll have to provide
it to the function that we're about to
create so back to the functions we
create a new file i'll say
three and we'll call this product
js and then like i already previously
mentioned
later i'll show you how we can combine
both of them
in one function because it also is a
possibility
i first would want to start with my
hello code
copy and paste and of course i didn't
copy that
so copy and paste and i'll say
single product here single product
let's restart the sucker so stop
npm run metal fire i believe that was
the command
then i'll close it i don't need the new
tab open
and in here instead of air table we
already know that that functionality
works
let's just go with product
product and of course i can see that i
have
a single product and eventually the way
it's gonna work
is something like this where
i have my products okay awesome and then
once i click on a product
remember i navigate to product html
and then i use my query string parameter
now i'll use the front-end
javascript so the javascript code we're
about to write in the product
js on our front end in the example
i'll grab this one and
i'll make a fetch request to my
serverless function and essentially i'll
pass
this value to my serverless function
so now the question is well how we can
check for those values well if we go
back to our url and in this case i'll
zoom in
we can do the same thing we can just go
with
question mark and then of course i'll
just keep the name the way it is
but remember sky is the limit you can
call this bugs bunny and for time being
i'll just pass in
one so we pass this in we still
have the girth request and all that but
notice something interesting right now
where once we go back remember the event
right
so event and that was useful info about
the request and now i'll open up the
terminal
of course i cannot see anything right
now but if i'll go back and refresh
i should see the object and what's
really interesting
is that i have this query string
parameters object
now it's always going to be an object
even if nothing
is provided but what's really cool i
have this key
and of course it has the value of one
so now of course what i could do is just
destructure that id
out of the query string parameters and i
can check if
the value is provided if there is an id
then i can try to get the data about
that product
using the airtable node if not then i'll
just send back hey listen
you did not provide the id and for this
serverless function
i need to have the id in order to
retrieve the data
about the product all right so
how we can do that well i could set up a
const id
and i'll right away the structure and
this is coming from
event and query query
string parameters parameters like so
because i can see that they're over here
so we go with
event query string parameters make sure
that you either copy or write exactly
how the property name is otherwise it's
not going to work and here i'm checking
for the id
and i'll right away set up the if
statement where if the id
is not provided then i'll right away
send back the 400
where i'll say please provide product id
and the way it's going to look like
we're going to go with if id
is there awesome we'll do some kind of
functionality
so for time being we'll just say single
product so we'll keep it the way it is
however if it's not then we're just
going to go with
400 and we'll say there was an error
or you're not let's just say please
provide
product id and keep in mind one thing
where we need to have these returns of
course
because we know that in javascript if we
hit this
if if we don't have the return we'll
always
end up reading the rest of the code
which in our case of course is going to
be the error
so now if we go back i should see the
single product if the id
is there but if the id is not there so
if i just remove it
not only we have please provide product
id
keep in mind i still can provide
my key value pairs over here i can
provide the name
i can provide i don't know whatever i
want here
remember sky's the limit we can add as
many as we would want
in our case we are just looking for the
id
the object will always be there but i'm
checking for the property if the
property is provided awesome
we'll do something if not then of course
we're just sending back 400 that well
we're looking for the id so now of
course
i would want to use that data that id
and
fetch info about the product so i'll use
again air table node
that's why i'll just copy these lines of
code there's really no need to retype it
from the scratch
so let's copy from the error table js
navigate back to the product js copy and
paste again we have dot env because i
want to access
the variable the error table api key
then i have still the same base and i
have the product
and now in the if block if i have the id
well now i would want to communicate
with the air table
and see whether i'm getting back the id
so the way it's going to look like first
i'm going to remove
this return for time being i'll close
my sidebar and we'll just take a look at
the try and catch so
go here with try catch and
we'll wait for the air table for
instance
and the method name in the airtable node
is retrieve so we pass in the id
so i'm going to say const product
is equal to a weight and
then air table and then
also retrieve like i said that was the
method name and then we pass
in the id now the problem here is that
the server's function is going to be
kind of hanging because
id will be there but there's no response
so in this case let's just go back to
the same one
and i'm sorry i said to remove it let's
just go with
status code status code i believe right
so status
is code of 200
and as far as the body i'll say
single product single single product
my bad sorry i said to delete but
actually we'll keep it
and now what i would want is just take a
look at the
product because i would want to showcase
that there's going to be a case where
product exists and then of course
we'll have a error as well meaning
there might be a case where product
doesn't exist and this is going to be
the case right now because i'm gonna go
with just id
and then one so we'll
refresh it one more time and for some
reason we removed it here
so say product number three and
now we fetch the single product
but what i'm more interested is my
console
because if i cannot get the product by
that id
that i'm passing in and of course there
is no product with an id of three
that we just passed in then i'm going to
get back this
object we the property of error
and it's important because we'll set up
our logic over here
where i'll say if the product that i'm
getting back
has the property of error well that
means that i cannot find
that product correct however if the
property of error is not going to be
there
then i know that i'm getting back that
product
so inside of the try catch block
we'll set up one more if statement we'll
say
product error and if that is the case
then let's grab one of the returns it
doesn't really matter which one because
we'll set up a specific info anyway so
now of course it's not going to be a
status code
of 200 since it is a error
and if you cannot find the resource then
the status code is
404 and in the body
i'll set this up as a template string
and we're going to go with no product
with id and then we'll just set up
our id and now again let's test it out
one more time where once we refresh
we should get no product with an id
off three beautiful so now we can see
that we cannot get that product
now of course i would want to get the id
that does exist
so i'm just going to change this around
a little bit where i'm going to go to
the
airtable function and just grab
any of these ids it doesn't really
matter which one
as long as you copy and paste the whole
value you're going to be in good shape
so copy that one and again we'll
navigate
back to the product then
we want to set up the question mark and
then the id
and copy and paste the value so now of
course we
should get the single product because
this actual product does exist
so in this case of course the product
error property
is not there so we are in good shape so
if that is the case i'll take my return
the one that i have below the try and
catch block
cut it out and then if the product
error doesn't exist then of course
there's going to be a return
and in this case we're returning 200 and
of course we still need to use the json
stringify
we go with json stringify and we pass
in the product now there's also
a possibility for the error but i can
tell you honestly that
with this airtable node they technically
don't throw that error so
i'll copy this one here just
so we are on the same page but tell me
honestly
when i was building it i was never
hitting this one so i'm going to call it
404 no product
found with this id and just to go over
one more time
so of course we set up the air table
that stays the same
and then here in the serverless function
we use our event object and on event
object we have this
query string parameters where we can
access the
query string parameters that are set on
the url
and the object will always exist so
that's why i'm not checking whether it
exists i know that it will always exist
but
i'm checking for specific property and
in my case
the property name is id and then
i'm communicating with airtable node
where i use the method of retrieve
if the product comes back with another
property that means that
there's no such product so return 404 so
product doesn't exist
if that's not the case then we return
200
and we just stringify the product
whatever we're getting back
and then of course we also have the
catch where
if there's some kind of issue with our
table now then we
return 400 or you know in this case
i think it's better with 500 let's just
stay consistent and i'm going to go 500
and i'll say server error or something
like that server error
because again there's some libraries
that would throw
the error here in a catch in the air
table node they
actually provide the product with an
error so that is the difference
that's why i'm saying that most likely
you won't hit this one but
let's just add it there for the sake of
consistency
and then lastly i have 400 and that is
happening
if the id is not provided at all so then
of course i want to throw
please provide product id and now once
we navigate back to the url and if you
don't change
anything about the id
you should get the single product and
this is the time where we get the id
notice we have the fields we have the
price like i previously mentioned
image is an array and it is
an array and we're looking for the first
item and then
this is the url where the actual image
is sitting now if i remove or if i add
some
extra character now i should have no
product
with an id of whatever i provided over
here
so if i again set up the correct id i
should get back to response hopefully
everything is clear
and now we can move back to the front
end
and actually set up the fetch request to
our product serverless function
and retrieve this info about specific
product
but not bad we have our single
product function in place so now of
course
we just need to set up the functionality
in front end
where when this page loads the product
html we fetch info
about specific product the id
of which has been provided over here in
the url
and then we just update this instead of
this generic single product
and generic photo and all that we'll get
that dynamic data about specific
product so let's do this people we're
going to navigate
back to our air table and in this case
we're not looking for index html
we're not looking for app.js we're
looking for
product html like i said
we have the title by the way should
probably change this to
a single product then we have the nav
like previously then we have a link to
navigate back to all the products keep
in mind that this is not back to all the
examples
this is still within the example number
three
the index.html and then we have this
generic data
about the single product which we're
going to use a little bit later
once we set up proper fetch request
now the gotcha here is that we're not
working with app.js
so this is why we would want to go to
product.js
this is where we'll set up the info
fetch data about that specific product
and we're going to start by selecting
the result
again the div or i don't know
let's check i think it was a div but
just to make sure i'm going to go with
result and yeah
that is a diff my apologies for
the detour i'll save it over here and
we're going to go with the result
so select the node and we do that with
document query selector
and we're looking for the class of
result
and then once we have selected the
result then again we would want to set
up a fetch
so we go with const and we'll say fetch
product i guess in this case
so fetch and product that's the function
name
again it's going to be a sync since
we'll have some asynchronous actions
and we want to right away fetch the
product
let's start with simple console.log and
we'll just say single
product page let's save it
and again we need to go back to our
starter
and we need to navigate back to all the
products i'll open up the console
and at the moment should be empty and
then once we navigate here notice we
have
single product page awesome and we're
going to start by
setting up the loading where we have the
result
so in a product html like i said we have
div with the class of result
and then while we're still fetching data
i would want to
display loading so in the product
js i'll simply say result
in our html is equal and we're just
going to go with heading 2
and we're going to go with loading dot
dot dot dot
dot let's close the heading 2 and if
everything is correct
we should display loading there it is
now of course we have
our loading then i want to set up
try catch block because again we'll have
to set up
a request and in this case of course
it's going to be to our single
product correct so let's remove that
console log let's set up a
try catch and now 64 000
question how can we access that id
that we're passing in dynamically and
let me set this up over here
where i have the address of course in
the example
so how can i access this one and
in the vanilla.js world
we simply go with window location
and then search so back in the product
js
i'm going to go with const id is equal
to window
so that is the window object and then we
have location
and then we have a search property
and what you should see is exactly what
we're looking for
in the product js so let's go back
let's refresh and check it out now i
have the question mark
the id as well as the value and for
every product of course that value is
going to be different
now i'm not going to compare them but
i'm just telling you that even though
the photos are the same
please understand that this id will
always be unique
so what do we need to do well we just
need to grab this id
and we need to set up of course our
request
correct so we're going to go with cons
now i'll cancel lock this data
i'm not going to destructure it yet and
there's a reason why
and we're going to set this up to a
weight then again we go with axios
and then we go with get and now
what is the function name well we go
with forward slash
api then we have the product and in this
case though
we need to set this up as a template
string so my apologies it's not going to
be simple quotation mark
it's going to be a template string we go
with api
then number three just because i'm
annoying and we're going to go with a
function name
which is product and then since i access
everything
i have the question mark i have the id
and then the value
i simply need to pass in the id of
course there's ways how you can
get only specific id or the value but
we don't need to because our function
our product function
is actually looking for all this it's
looking for the question mark the id
and then the value correct that's how we
set up the function
and there's going to be also a case for
error
maybe so that's why i'll set up right
away
a catch where i'll say if there is an
error in our html
is simply going to be equal to template
string
we're going to go with heading 2 and
we're just going to go
with remember error and in axiorys it
was
response and then we have data
that's where the error is going to be
and we're going to go with heading 2.
now in order to simulate error
first of all let's just cancel log data
if it is successful
because i would want to try that first
so let's cancel log
or i'm sorry let's refresh and then
check it out now of course we have the
data
status is 200 which just means that yes
there is a product with that id and
then we have the data property and
inside of this data property
we have fields and basically why i'm
showing you that because in this case
notice how in our product
i didn't do any destructuring
i just grabbed the product and i sent it
back
to whoever is asking right in this case
of course that is my front end
and that's why we'll have to do a little
bit of the structuring
on the front end previously that wasn't
the case because of course
i did all the work e and the air table
so that is of course the difference
and by the way if you want to see the
whole structure there it is if you
navigate
directly to the servers function using
the browser but
of course you need to provide the value
for the id
and that value needs to be existing id
and since i would also want to try out
the
error i'm going to go here const id and
basically the way it works is i kind of
just
dump nothing in there so i'll go
with the value for id i'll say question
mark id and for example equal to one
so just change this value around and now
in a single product
once i fetch i should have no product
with an id of one so i'm just showing
you
what would be possible error so move
this up
i'll comment this out for your own
reference if you would ever want to
check
the error and we'll go back to a
valuable
id and then of course there is now we
have loading because
i have success and the only thing left
to do
is to destructure our data
and again let me repeat one more time
the data will be in the fields
because i really don't need the id in
this case i only want the fields
because inside of the fields this is
where i can get my values
and then we just need to wrap it in
nice html so start here
where at the moment i have access to the
whole data
but i'm actually going to the structure
data and then since data is an object
itself
this time i'm looking more specifically
to the
fields property in the data object
and once i have access to that i'm just
going to go to name
name description
then price and then the image and all of
that is coming
from the fields because that's the
property amp
and once i have all of this in place i'm
just going to go with
result in our html and this is where i
would want to navigate back to the
product
and now select starting with a comment
and ending with a comment but of course
do not
include the comments so start with
heading one
and end with a closing tag of the
article
now you can cut it out but in my case
i'm just going to copy
we'll go back and we'll right away set
up a template string
and copy and paste so now of course we
just need to
provide these values which are going to
be different
for every product for example for
heading 1 it's not going to be a single
product
we'll say name then article stays the
same
class stays the same the id or i'm sorry
the class for the image stays the same
what i would want to change is the url
that's going to be unique
so since i have template strings i just
interpolate the value
and we're going to go with image
remember it is an array
we're looking for item number one and
we're looking more specifically
for the url then again
interpolation we go with name
for the alternative then we have product
info
same deal for the third time already
we're getting
the name then for the price we're just
accessing the price property
and then you can probably already guess
what we're doing for description
just remove this dummy value and then
we'll just go for description
and now what should happen when we
navigate
single product there it is now i have
my product and if i go and select
different product
which now have different product
displayed
on a screen in the single product page
and next video i would want to show you
how we can combine
both functions in one because that is
still possible
and then we'll deploy it and then of
course i'll show you how we can add
those
airtable values to our netlify
so that way we don't get some weird bugs
beautiful
and before we deploy the project one
more time
on metalfi let me just showcase how we
could set up everything
in one serverless function now please
keep in mind two things
first it is optional you can definitely
keep it in two functions
there's no rule against that and
second there's going to be a lot of
copying pasting because i don't see the
point of
setting up everything from the scratch
so what we would want to do
is go back to the functions again just
because i'm annoying i'm going to go
with
three and then z because i would want to
display
this function last since i have one for
error table and one for product
so i'm gonna go with complete and i'm
gonna call this
js i do need to remember right away to
restart the server
we'll just go with npm run
and then of course netify we spin this
sucker up
and we'll start in the product now again
opens up a new tab i don't need a new
tab
what i want is to navigate to the
product so start over here
pretty much grab this whole info go back
copy and paste and once we have dumped
these values we just need to scroll down
and remove that return where we say
please provide
product id so remove this sucker over
here
and now of course i need to go back to
the air table
and also grab this logic
so say try and catch so you want to copy
that
and copy and paste below
so let's understand what's happening so
i have
one serverless function that is my url
where i go with
three hyphen z and then complete
so if there is an id
so if there is query string parameter
with the value
of id then i'm trying to get that
product
now if i'm not successful i'm returning
404
and i say no product with an id blah
blah blah
then if everything is fine i send back
the product
now if there's some weird error then of
course i send back the
500. now if i don't provide it
then of course i'm just getting the list
i say our table list
and then of course i'm getting all the
values and do the same spiel
where i iterate over them and i send
back the product
and if there is some kind of error again
i send back
the 500. so now of course in order to
test it out
first of all let's go to the browser i
think
that's going to be a bit safer where we
simply go with
localhost sorry not like then we're
going to go with
localhost we're looking for eight eight
eight
then forward slash then api and then we
go with
three and then what was the name
z and then complete in this case notice
how i'm not
providing the id correct
so this should give us all the products
okay hopefully that is clear and just
stay on the safe side i'll copy and
paste so i'll create a new tab
and then i'll grab this one id
i guess the first one and remember we
needed to add the query string
parameters we copy and paste
and this should give us the single id
correct and if i will tamper with
it if i'll try to get some kind of id
that doesn't exist then of course i'll
get this error
and now i'm going to go to the
examples and first in the object i'll
leave this one for your reference
because again the idea doesn't change so
we'll just copy and paste
and i'll comment this out and here we go
with three
z and then
complete like so and we're going to do
the same thing
in a single product so product js
what you would want to do of course is
to comment this out copy and paste
and uncomment this and we're just
changing the value here
for our serverless function so we go
with three hyphen
z and then complete
like so and if everything is correct
our application should still work so
let's refresh
i can see shoes and there it is i have
all four products so that didn't change
and if i take a look at the single
product
i still have access to the info
beautiful
now we just need to push this up to the
github add the environment variables
to our notify and at least the
example number three is going to be good
to go
not bad not bad i think we're in good
shape and we can push this up
to the github and then netfly will
automatically
start rebuilding our site so what i
would want
is to navigate to metalfi and i'm not
going to show you what kind of error you
would get
if you push this up without the
environment variables i think
it's just going to be waste of our time
so simply log in
and then if you remember in order to set
up
those environment variables we needed to
navigate to
domain settings then we're looking for
build and deploy keep on scrolling
and check it out here we have those
environment variables
so we click here on edit variables
then we navigate back to our project and
check it out
we have airtable api key so you need to
make sure that you use the same name of
course
otherwise it's not going to make sense
and you just want to pass
this value like so so you pass the value
save it and now we should be in good
shape
where again we would want to push this
up to the get-up
now let me stress something where if you
want this data
to be accessible on different apps
just like i showed you the previous
example with basic api
include these headers now i'm not
including them because
well there's no point i already showed
you the example
with the basic api and these ones i mean
i don't really care whether the
different api can access them
or not that's why i'm just skipping off
adding the headers
now if you have different app for
example react
app that will access that of course
make sure that you add them
make sure that you have those headers or
of course
add the function the serverless function
that we created for example
the z complete one to your react
project which by the way we'll cover
later in the course
basically at the very end when i show
you all kinds of functionality
with the vanilla.js approach i'll simply
show you how we can
also add the serverless function to
the react project for example so
hopefully that is clear
and i'm just going to go here to
the github one and i'll say
project project three or example for
let's do it this way example three
complete complete and then
there it is we just click on a check
mark
and then we push this up to the github
now the build should be pretty quick
there's not much to it so let's scroll
up
we see the deploys notice we have the
message example three complete and here
we're building of course building
building building
while netify is busy building my site
i'm going to remove
some of the tabs because again it's just
getting too busy over here
and you know what i think i'm also going
to close the airtable node 1.
if you ever want to double check whether
the code that i'm writing is correct of
course you can do it but
for the remainder of examples i'm just
going to tell you what is the method
name
and what do we need to provide looks
like we're in good shape
we have more functions that's awesome
we have site is live that should do it
so we can just navigate to our site and
we can check it out
we have the hello world basic api and
we're looking for a table
now we're fetching data from the air
table by the way
if you want to see it in action i'm just
going to remove the product
and say you know what this one is not
needed
and let's just wait we'll see how long
it takes and there it is within a matter
of seconds
we have our new updated data so we have
nice gui
which we can use to delete update create
whatever data and we can display it
right away
in our application and if i want to see
the single product
there is now i have my nike shoes
awesome i think we are in good shape and
we can continue
with our examples and at the very end
i'm going to show you how to set up
serverless functions
with react app now we're not going to
set up
all the previous examples in react app
that would be very time consuming but we
are going to
create a basic setup so you have a clear
idea of how to add the serverless
functions
to your react app and what are some
gotchas you need to be aware of
if you're wondering why i ended up
adding react project as well
essentially there are two reasons first
the time of recording react is by far
the most popular framework
so it's a good chance that most of the
course students use react
and second initially i used serverless
functions to set up
the api for my react course
and i've been getting a lot of questions
from my react core students
about that about the whole setup so it
only makes sense
if i cover all of the steps in details
if you want to see the app we are going
to be making navigate to url
serverlessfunk react example
again the url is serverless dash
func dash react dash example
dot middle phy dot app and again
it's not going to be super complex app
however
we'll take a look at how we can fetch
data
from our previous project remember our
second example
was local data but remember we added
that header
so we can access that data from other
apps
that's going to be our first example and
second example
we'll take a look at how we can add a
serverless function to our react
app and essentially fetch
data in react component from
our own app essentially we'll have
our react app we'll have the serverless
function
that fetches product data from the air
table
and then instead of going to the third
party api
and fetching some data we'll fetch it
from within our own server
because of course we'll have the
serverless function
in our project and also take a look at
how we can set up a
single page with react router dom
as well and of course if something is
iffy at the moment
as we're working on the examples i'll
cover everything
in greater detail and also since
it is a react app there are going to be
some gotchas
when it comes to deployment so of course
i'll cover them
as well now in order to follow along
with a project
you will need a starter so you'll need
to navigate
back to my github and again the handle
is
john smilga and then you're looking for
serverless funk react and starter
now there's a complete one as well but
again the starter is going to be in a
repo
by the name of serverless funk react
star go there and just follow along with
the videos
and once i'm at the repo as always you
can fork it you can download
or you can simply clone which is gonna
be my option
so i'm gonna get the url i'm gonna
navigate back
now if you want you can leave this one
on desktop it doesn't really matter
and i'm just going to open up a new one
so cd
let's stop let's just zoom in though
desktop and then we're looking for git
clone and copy and paste
that's my starter so i'll open up a new
window
in my text error and since it is a react
app
and i used create react app to
set it up of course we'll have to
install dependencies and it's going to
take
more time than the previous starter
so in this case we need to run npm
install and while the dependencies are
being installed
i'm just going to showcase that it is
pretty traditional react app
where we have the public here of course
we have index.html if you want
you can change the title at the moment i
have serverless
and react starter so i think in my case
i'm just going to remove the starter
then we have the source this is where
we'll do most of our work
so i have the app.js here with just a
heading 2
and as a side note i believe this is a
react
17 and if you take a look
in react 17 we don't need anymore that
import react from react
now as we'll be creating our own
components
since i'm using the snippet i believe
it's still
injects that import react from react but
just keep in mind that
with react 17 you don't need to do that
anymore
now in the source we also have index css
for all our styles as well as the index
js where at the moment we have app but
eventually this is where we'll set up
react router dom
then we have get ignored essentially the
files that are going to be ignored
by the source control now we're mainly
interested
in this dot env and of course we have
netify tamil file
where we point to the functions folder
which we haven't created yet
as well as setup redirect now since
it is a react app there is going to be a
few more things
that we'll add to this network tamil
file but
we'll do that at the very end because
it's just important
for deployment and then we have
package.json where of course
we have all the packages that
react needs as well as few of our own
so we have axiorys again we have adder
table node
and of course i'll explain each package
once
we add it to the project and in the
readme you'll just
find a setup for the tamil one so this
is going to be
the complete setup and also
have a build command and of course i'll
talk about it
again once we are ready to deploy the
project
and once we're done with the setup since
we have
nettle fire package technically we can
run npm
run nettle file again that is always an
option because notice
i have the script command over here the
thing is
for the first example for the basic
setup
i would just want to spin up the react
server so that one is done with npm
start
because i would want to showcase that
with the first example we don't need
netfly server in place so in this case
i'm just going to go
with npm start and that should spin up a
server
on local host 3000. again
keep in mind there's a difference
there's a localhost 3000
where we have app served by
create react app server and then
eventually
once we add the serverless function to
our react app we'll have to spin up our
server
on localhost 888 and that is going to be
done
using the npm or on netfly
and once you spin up the react server
this is what you should see
on screen and now of course we're ready
to work on our
first example beautiful so now let's
work on our first
example this is going to be the basic
setup where
if you remember as our second
example we served a
local api essentially the data was local
however remember we added the header
so that just meant that we can access
this data
from any app and if you
need to jog your memory i'm gonna go to
serverless functions course
so that's the url and then if you take a
look at the basic api remember
we set this up with local data now i'm
not really interested in this case in
the front end
what i'm interested is the api so
i'll remove that part of the url and
we're just going to go with api 2
and then basic api so that's the data
that i'm looking for and now what i
would want
is to fetch this data from this url
so from the project that is already
hosted on metalfi
and just render it in my react app
now here's the thing if you want you can
grab this url
essentially from my complete project and
then you're just looking for
api to basic however i would suggest
grabbing this data from your own project
because
eventually if i'll see too many requests
so
if it's going to exceed that 125
000 that metal file gives for free then
of course i'll just remove
that header and you'll get a course
error
just keep that in mind if there's not
going to be too many requests
you should be able to use this url but
there's going to be too many
i'll just remove that header and then of
course you'll get the course error
now if you deployed your own project you
should always have
access to that url as well so i'm going
to copy
this url i'm going to head back to my
project
and then in the source so let me zoom in
that's my source
i want to create a new file and i'm just
going to call this
basic js again in react 17 we don't need
to import
react from react but since i'm using my
snippets
i'm just going to import it anyway
notice here
we have import react from react and
that's my basin component
and i would also want to right away
import
two more things i would want to get use
effect
since we'll set up fetch as well as use
state since i would like to store those
products somewhere and i'll store it
in state as well as axios from
axios just because i think it's going to
be easier than the regular fetch
and we're importing this from the axe us
library
and once i have my imports i'll right
away set up my url so const url
is equal to my string and let me set it
up
in quotation marks like so and once i
have added the string
then of course i would want to set up my
state value
and you know what before we do anything
why don't we set up
a section here and just let's see
whether we're getting some kind of
return so go here with section
and say hello from basic
example like so let's save that and then
of course we need to navigate
to app.js import that component
the basic one so import basic
from and then basic component and
since there's going to be the air table
component as well i'll set this up as
react fragment since i cannot return to
adjacent components
so this is going to be my parent one and
i'll simply render
my basic component i'll close the
sidebar
and i'll navigate back to localhost 3000
and there it is now half hello from
basic example let's see what is my zoom
level
that should do it and then i'm going to
go back to the basic one and like i said
first i would want to set up state value
for the product
and in the beginning it's just going to
be a empty array product
set product here and that is equal to my
use state and it's just going to be an
empty array
that's good then i'll set up a fetch
data or fetch products function which is
going to run
when our component amounts and it's
going to be
synchronous and that's why i will set up
right away
a sync function so const fetch
fetch data and that one is equal to
my sync function now i'm not going to
pass anything in there
we'll just say that it is a function
we'll set up try catch
we're not going to do anything if there
is an error let's just skip that part
and i would want to right away the
structure of the data
out of the axios because remember with
axiorys we get
a giant object however the data that
we're looking for is sitting in data
property
and i'm just destruction right away so
go with axios.get
and i'll pass the url again let me
repeat
you can use this url however if you get
the course
error that just means that you'll have
to use the
data from your own app that you have
deployed because of course
the generous 125
000 requests that the netlife offers
have been exceeded all right and then
we'll go with
set products and we'll just pass in data
so initially this is going to be an
empty array and then
once the component mounts in the product
has a state value i should have these
values
and like i said i'll do that once the
component mounts
that's why we'll run our used effect
here
and i'll just pass in empty array
and let's just say fetch data let's
invoke it
now if you want we can cancel log or we
can simply use react devtools let's do
it this way
let's go to serverlessreact i'll refresh
we'll inspect and we go to components
there is our app and there's our basic
component and notice the state
now of course state has the product
value awesome and once we have the
products then of course i just need to
work on my return
like i said this is going to be very
simple example where essentially i would
want to set up
some kind of styling so i'll pass some
classes here as well
we'll say section section center and
then
we're going to go with div with the
class of title inside of the title
we're going to set up a heading 2 with
text of basic
setup and let's add the underline as
well
so we're going to have div with the
class of title underline
and once we save it this is what we
should see the basic setup
and now of course i just want to iterate
over my products
and then for every product return a
article
so right after the title div we're going
to set up another div with the class of
products
and inside there we're going to go with
product map so we're mapping over the
state value
each and every product is going to be
represented by the parameter of
product and then i know that
inside of that product inside of that
object i have properties of id
image which is an object itself however
there's a url
property that i'm interested this one
this is going to give me that image and
then of course you know the rest you
know the name
as well as the price just destructure
that right away
i'm going to go with const and we're
looking for id
and we'll need that for the key because
of course this is react
and we're looking for url here as well
then price
as well as name and that one is coming
from the product like so and once we
have the
of this data then like i said we just
need to worry about our return
and i'm returning an article and i'll
close this one
let's add a class name here right away
product
and remember in react if we have a list
we need to have the key prop
and inside of the key prop we just need
to pass something unique
and in our case of course that is an id
then let's set up our image
for the source we'll use the url for the
alternative
we use the name and then of course
i'll set up the info so deal with the
class of
info and inside of the info
what i would want is to go with heading
5
and we'll pass in the name
name and then we have another one
and this is going to be the price so
here let's go with price
and we'll add a little bit of styling
that's why i'll have class name of price
and let's add a dollar sign as well
so let's add this one let's save it and
this is what we should see
on the screen again extremely basic
setup
where if you want to set up the api
that's going to be consumed
by multiple applications you simply
create a project
you set up the serverless function don't
forget about the header
otherwise you'll get course errors you
deploy that project
which in my case of course is this one
serverless functions course
and then that's my function and of
course
once it's live from any application
you can access this data just keep in
mind that
as far as the free tier it is 125
requests and
again if you have many users trust me
you'll run out of that quickly
if it's just you using of course you
should be
in good shape so we're done with our
basic example now of course
let's take a look at how we can add our
serverless function
to our react app because in this case
we're simply fetching from
external api now i would want to add
the server list function to our project
and of course we'll be fetching from our
own server
nice and we're going to start setting up
our serverless function so i'll split
this up
in a few videos so the videos are not
extremely
long and we'll start by creating
component
and i'll say here error table that's
going to be my name our table.js
and again i'm using my snippets to
create my component
and i'll say hello from
airtable so all right we save that one
then again we navigate to app.js import
and then we're importing airtable from
and the component name and then of
course right after the basic one
i would want to render let's save it and
if i navigate to localhost 3000 i should
have hello
from airtable awesome once that one is
in place
now of course i would want to create my
serverless function
and remember in little fight tamil we
already
have the command where we point
to the functions folder so of course we
need to create a folder
and then we have a redirect as well
so in the root i'll create a new folder
and i'll call this functions of course
so
so let me zoom in notice functions
folder and then within the functions
folder
i'll create a new file and i'll call
this product
and js now here's what i would want
i would want to get that function
where i combined both the
value for all the product and then for
the specific one
and if you need to jog your memory what
am i talking about well
i'm gonna open up a new window and now
i'm grabbing our
serverless functions so the previous
project
i'll dump it and then let me just
showcase where
i'll close everything that i have
currently open
and we're just looking in the functions
and then we're looking for that complete
one
that's the code that i would want to get
again i don't see the point of retyping
everything from the scratch
just go back to the starter the
serverless function starter
go to the complete one or if you don't
have the complete one then of course
get the code from both of these ones so
you'll have to set up
two functions in my case i have the code
for both of them
so i'll copy this one and keep in mind
that these values are not changing we
just need to create that
dot envy and i also install dot env
package
in our react one so you should have
access to that one
as well as air table mode so save it
or i'm sorry i guess copy that navigate
to the functions and product so this is
going to be the react app
copy and paste that should be the code
and of course we right away can create a
dot envy file
because we'll be looking for this value
and we still need to
use the dot env even though it is a
react app one
and then get the secret key from
your air table again i'll copy and paste
it
and then i should have the product
available
now at this point though i don't want to
run this on localhost 3000
here's the key now i have a
serverless function so of course at this
point what i would want
is to run npm and you know what let me
just clear the console first so npm
and then run and netify and you'll
notice something
really really cool where natalify cli
is very smart it can see that we
have a react app with create react app
so there's going to be two apps there's
going to be
one that's served on localhost 3000
so that is going to be the create react
app
and then there's going to be one again
on localhost 888.
see notice here we have still this
localhost 3000
and by the way if you don't believe me
see over here
localhost 3000 so we still have this app
in place now the gacha of course is
following where
of course since we have our server list
function
i want to run the rest of my code
essentially i want to test the rest of
my code
on localhost 888 because on localhost
3000 i will have
no access to my serverless function so
let's check it out
we're going to go here with api and
we're not looking for one hello
we're looking for products why because
that's how i named
my serverless function and now if
everything is correct
i should see my product why well because
i have all the code in there right
i already have let me open up my
products yep there it is
so i have dot env so i can get my
environment variables i get the airtable
node
i get the base i already have the api
key
i'm looking for the table by the name of
product everything exactly the same
and then the rest of the functionality
and
once we have this data now of course i
can
fetch it in my air table component
it's all we have to do similarly to what
we did
with a vanilla js approach
beautiful so now let's just set up our
return
and we're going to do that first i'll
remove the tab
for the github and again you can keep
the 3000 open if you want but
i'll go to 888 like so
so as you can see we still have our app
and now of course i'll just want to work
on this component and i think i can
close this one as well
so this is the url to the complete
project where we were getting the two
basic api so this is where we're getting
that function
and then the data that we are displaying
in our basic component so close this one
i'll just leave
the product function open just in case
i want to take a look at the values but
should be pretty straightforward
where we have array and then that's not
what i wanted
where we have array we have some objects
and then inside of the object
we just have four properties id name url
and price and of course in the error
table component i would just want to
fetch it
from my function so that's not going to
be a external api
i'm sorry external url it's going to be
local url
it's going to be coming from my own
server and then we'll do the same thing
iterate
over data and just render
those products so let's navigate back
we are and by the way this probably
is my serverless function one starter
so let me close it i don't need it
anymore
and i want to navigate to the react
project
please don't confuse the two now i would
want to do my work over here
i'll close the terminal and
we'll need to import some stuff as well
just like we did in the basic one
so we're going to go with use effect
again we use
use state and much of the functionality
as you can tell is going to be pretty
similar the only difference of course
is the different url and also when
we are getting the data when we're
destruction
of course we have right away four
properties so technically
you can copy and paste and then just
alter the data
in my case i'll rewrite it from the
scratch because i think it's just going
to be
a bit more easier to understand so we're
going to go again with axios
for easier fetch requests so we're going
to go with axios
and then eventually there's going to be
a link component from react router dom
but we're not going to set that up right
now and we're looking for
url and then forward slash api
and then product why well because that's
where our serverless function is located
then we have our airtable component of
course where we go with const
product again same deal and set
that is equal to our use state
use state and we pass in empty array
like so
and same deal we set up fetch data
so const fetch
and data and that is our function
it's going to be in a sync function
right away and instead of this function
again we go with
try catch and we'll just be looking for
data
coming from axios and i'll set it equal
to that
so go with await axios.get
and we'll pass in the url so this is
going to be the url
on our own server where we have the
product
and then we just go to set product and
pass in data again
if you want you can console log it in my
case i think i'm just going to use the
react devtools so localhost 888
inspect and if we take a look at the
components and airtable one
at the moment state is empty now why is
the state empty because i haven't called
the use effect yet
so we're going to go here with use
effect
and again we'll pass in our callback
function of course
and then we'll say that dependency array
is going to be empty
and we'll just say fetch data so once we
fetch the data
in the r table yep there it is of course
now our state has
three values our three products and
similarly to the
basic one like i said we're going to go
with section we'll add some classes here
we'll say section section center
and then inside of this section we're
just gonna go
with our title again subtitle
and we'll say heading to our table
and let's add that underline as well
just because it looks better
on that line all right awesome and then
same deal we're just iterating over the
products
so let's set up a dave with the class of
products and then inside of it
we go with products we're mapping over
and you already know the deal
every product is gonna be an object and
then
what i would want is set up
some kind of parameter in my case
product
and i'll write away the structure id url
then price and name and eventually this
is going to be linked to
a separate page but we haven't set up
our react router dom yet
that's why for time being it is going to
be
a article and then eventually we'll set
it up as a link
so let's go with article and we need to
add a class name again of
product as you can see the styling is
exactly the same we're going to go with
key
is equal to id
and inside of this article i want to set
up again my image
i'll use the source and that will be url
then we'll add a name here of course
and then we would want to have a deal
with the class of info
and two heading fives one for name and
one for price
so let's set this up i'm going to go
name copy and paste
i would want to close it of course and
this is not going to be named it's going
to be price
let's add here a dollar sign as well
and we're going to add a class of price
so once we save it and we navigate
back to our project we should see
two products one coming from the basic
setup
this is of course where we fetch the
third-party api
which by the way we created ourselves
with metal file functions
and then the second one is coming from
our own
server so this is where we set up a
serverless function
for our own react project so you have
two flavors
that's really up to you which one you
would like to choose and
next video i'll show you how we can set
up
separate pages now if you remember when
we were setting up our
functions for airtable products when we
combined
two of them one for all the products and
one for single product
the result was following where if we
navigate
to the url of api online whatever
is the function name which in our case
is product we're going to get
all the products however if i
navigate to localhost 888
and then we're going to go with api and
again the name is
product and if we pass in the query
string
where we set up the id and of course id
needs to have some kind of value meaning
it needs to be
a valid id otherwise we'll split back
the error
then of course we'll get the info about
that one
specific product and we'll use this info
to build
a single page where of course in the
basic setup we don't have that one
but in the air table if i click on the
link
on the product then of course i navigate
to a
single product page and then i fetch the
data
about that one specific product and of
course logic hasn't changed so if i'll
pass
the id that doesn't return any product
i'll just get a no product with an id
off whatever
and if we take a look at the console we
should get a 404 so in console of course
there is
i have 404 since that is the response
that we're sending from the product so
if we try to retrieve the product with
that id
um there's no such product so in the
airtable node if there's a
product or i'm sorry error property on a
product
then of course we just return 404
now for this one i will use the react
router dom
because i think it's just going to be
easier
and the way we'll set this up in the
source let's create a new file
i'll call this product js again i'll use
my snippets and i'll say single
product and then in this case i'll set
this up in the index
js where of course we would need to have
few imports
from the reactor or dominant let me
close the sidebar
we go here with import we look for
browser router as
router then we're looking for route
and all of that is coming from react
router dom
now i'm not going to set up the error
page that's why i'm not going to use the
switch statement
so just go with browser router as router
and route
and then of course i also would want to
import that single product
so the way my setup is gonna work if i
navigate to the home page
i'll have basic setup and air table so
essentially that is going to be my app
component
and then for a single product i'll
return that
product component that we just set up
with that dummy value that we're
returning so i'll go with
product from and product component
and by the way i don't know why it's not
returning a product let me see
because i named it products my bad so
rename
and we're going to go with product and
again we're
importing from the product and now let's
set up
a structure for the react router where
we go with
router and then inside of the router we
will have
two paths basically two routes one path
is going to be a home page and in this
case i'll set it up as
exact because why not and instead of
this route
let's see exact we have as true
and then inside of this route i would
want to render my app like i said
app component and then of course
i'll set up another route and this one
will be to that
single product just keep in mind that of
course it is going to be a placeholder
we set up the page for the single
product
and we'll have to use of course url
parameters
or for the path i'm going to go forward
slash
and i'll remove that exact one and we'll
say here colon
and product id so eventually of course
there's going to be a link
we'll pass that id and then in that
single product
we'll get it and i guess let's just
start there
we're back in the airtable.js i'm going
to go back and i'll
import a link from react router dom from
react router dom and then instead of the
article
we'll return a link and now we just need
to make this dynamic
where we'll set up two and we need to go
with template literal
and essentially i would want to access
that id
so i'll say forward slash and then id
and since i have set up react or dom now
of course i'm passing in this product id
so every time i'll click on this product
which is a link i'm going to navigate to
the product page
but i'll pass the product id
like so and again if you're not familiar
with the setup please watch
other videos where i show how it's done
as far as react rather than so save the
airtable js
and if we navigate to our current
product or i'm sorry
our current project then we can refresh
just so we can start from scratch and
there it is now have
link outside of the router so if you get
this bug we simply need to navigate back
to the injects and just check and there
it is of course
i have two setups for app i didn't
remove it
so we have one app where we pass it in
the route
and then we have a product that we
passed in the second route
so make sure that you remove that app
because otherwise you'll get that
error let me refresh and there it is now
i have the basic setup
and here i have the error table so now
since these ones are links and we can
clearly see that
since our cursor is changing as we hover
over it
notice how we navigate to the product
component
but i pass this id like so
and i can navigate back of course and
you'll see that
this value will be different so each and
every time
we click on a product we pass the
product id in our url because
we use url parameters from react router
down
and now we simply need to go to the
product js
our component and we just need to
probably set up the loading
we need to set up use params which is a
hook from react router down because
of course i would want to get that id
and then i would just want to
render my product that's all we have to
do
so let's go to the product js
and you know what i'll close everything
that i have currently open in my editor
just so it's cleaner so we're going to
go with product
js and here there's going to be a few
more things that are coming from react
we have use state we have use
effect like so and i also want to get
the x here's because of course
we'll be fetching product data from
our product function we'll just add that
query parameter there axios
from axios like so and then we also have
a link because there's going to be a
link back home
back to the home page and also use param
since i would want to access
that product id and that one is coming
from
react router dom and once we have this
setup
in the product and by the way since the
name originally was
product that's why i have both for
component
as well as export as product so i'll
change it now you don't have to there's
a default export so it doesn't really
matter but
in my case i will then let's set up
loading
since it might take a little bit of time
set
loading and by default it's going to be
true so
use state we'll set this equal to true
then we'll go with our product so const
product and we'll set set product
equal i guess let's just start with null
so by default it's going to be null and
then in order to get
that product id that we have in the url
we simply go with const
and we're going to get back the object
so for time being let's just go with
data and i'll
invoke that use params hook that is
coming
from reactor or num and i'll cancel log
the data
and you'll see that every time we
navigate
to our product page
will have in a console a id
and let's see so we have used params
data
and for some reason i cannot see there
it is
now once i refresh i have product id and
here i have the value
now we'll need this value because of
course we want to set up
another fetch request right so i'll
write away
the structure product id and of course
if you named it
bugs bunny in the index.js just make
sure
that you use the same value in my case i
named it
product and then uppercase id that's why
in the product component
i'll use the same name and then the same
deal
we go with const fetch and we'll call
this
data again let's just stay consistent
let's name it all the time the same and
again we have try catch
now the url is going to be a bit
different right so we're going to go
const
data that is going to be my product data
that is coming back
await axios and then get
and now of course the url will set it up
as a template literal why
because we'll pass in this product id
and remember
in order to get info about single
product we went with
api product like so
then we need to have question mark id
and then
whatever is the product id so we go with
product id and if everything is correct
i'm gonna go with
set product equal to data just keep in
mind one thing that
we'll have to do a little bit of the
structuring here
let's see we have the id and what we're
actually looking for
is the fields property so we'll have to
do a little bit of extra work
but regardless whether we get the data
or there's an error i would always want
to set loading
to false set loading and now one is
equal to false
and once this is in place i'm just going
to go with
use effect and pass in my callback
function
empty dependency array and let's just
say
fetch and data we will invoke it
and let's set up a if statement if we're
loading
and then if we're not loading then of
course let's just destructure the data
so we're going to go with if loading
that is the case
then i would want to return a section
and i'll add some classes here so say
class name
section section center
and then instead of this section we'll
set up a heading two
we loading dot dot dot okay that's good
and then if we're not loading then of
course there's going to be a return but
what i would want to do first is right
away the structure
what i'm looking for from my product now
i'm not going to cancel log
the data because i already showed you in
the browser but what i would want
is to go with fields so that is coming
from the product and again we're able to
access that
because i'm assuming that there is no
error if you want to set it up with
error of course
you just need to add more data and
more specifically from the fields i
would want to right away get
name then description
and then price as well as the image
and that one is coming from the fields
and i'll just cancel log the name i'm
not going to cancel like rest of them
we can navigate back to our
project and i'll spin this up and there
it is i have blue
sneakers so that means that i have
access to the data
i'll navigate back to my home page and
i'll go with this one i should have
pink shoes so i'm loading for a second
and then i display these pink shoes
so now of course we simply need to set
up our return
so we're gonna go here with a section
and then let's remove it we'll set up
some classes
as well so class name section section
center and then instead of the section
let's
set up that link back home so link to
and we're navigating back home so go
with forward slash
and also let's add a little bit of
styling off a link
now instead of the link what i would
want
is some kind of text so say back
home like so let's save that one and
then
right after the link let's set up a div
and then instead of that they will have
a title div and then again the same deal
we're going to go with heading to in
this case the name will be dynamic
that's where i'll access the name
and i'll add that title underline
as well let's save it there it is now we
have pink shoes as well as the link
back home and it doesn't look like i
added css so
i'll have to capitalize it myself and of
course i can do it
also if we go to the css but
i'll skip that part and then
okay we have the div and
right next to this div we're gonna have
the article
article and the class name will be
single
product like so and we're going to go
with an image again there's going to be
a class eventually
so why don't we add right away the css
we'll say single product and then img
and now of course for the source we need
to look for the image but remember
we were not doing any destructuring in
our api
so we need to go with image 0 because
image is an array and we're looking for
the first item
then url and then we'll have access to
the image
now again i'll add the name for my
alternative
and then we simply want a div with
two values or three values apologies we
also have description in this case so
go with heading 5 and we're looking for
a name
then copy and paste this is where the
price
is going to be displayed so class name
and price and of course i'm looking for
the value of price
and then lastly we have a paragraph of
description that's all we have to do
so description here and there it is
if we now get back to the browser this
is what we should see
so once we refresh this is going to be
our look
now there's one thing missing here and
that is the fact that
div needs to be placed within the
article my bad
so now of course we have the css as well
so navigate and there it is now we have
our single product setup as well
all right and once we're done with our
project
now of course it's time to deploy it
however
there are some gotchas that i would like
to cover when it comes to
react projects and deploying them with
serverless functions on metal file
that's well first go back to the metal
phyton and by the way
if you want to see the code we'll be
typing just navigate to
a readme and first what i would want is
to add a build command
because remember with create react app
we have a command that builds our
project right
so we need to tell netfly hey what is
the command
and we need to go with command and then
of course the value is
npm or unbuild and then we need to
showcase a
publish directory and we do that by
pointing to
forward slash and build so let's do that
i'm gonna go to my tamil file which i
cannot find for some reason
and again just to stay consistent let's
add
these tabs here and what i would want
is to have a command that was the name
so we go here and we can go in front of
the functions or after
i don't think it really matters but i
think i'm gonna set it up before
command is equal to npm
run and then we go with build
so then i would want to go with my
publish
directory and that one will be equal to
a
forward slash and build so that's
out of the way and then we have one more
thing
if you took my react course you know
that once
we deploy a react app that has
react power dom we actually need to set
up
redirect and just to showcase that i'm
gonna go
to github i'm looking for the comfy
sloth that was our react project the
e-commerce project the big project we
built
during the course and if you take a look
at the public folder
you'll notice this redirects file and
here we simply say that
every route is going to be redirected to
index
html now if you add
this file with that code to
react project what's going to happen
well these redirects that we have for
our functions
is not going to work so either you need
to
remove this redirect for the api
or you would need to remove that file
now there's a solution though
where i can still keep my api option so
that's just going to make it easier
and then of course i can just set up
another setup redirect
because if you don't then every time
there's going to be
a path to api it's going to be
redirected home
and then you won't be able to access
that
from your code remember we have been
using
all the time this forward slash api and
then the function name
but if we add this file the redirect
file
in the public folder then our
functionality won't work
now if you don't add this redirect file
then of course the another issue is that
your react router won't work so the
solution is following where
we set up another set of redirect
so we don't create a file in a public we
don't pass it in
instead what we do is we go with
redirect again
and we just type out that anything from
and in this case of course we're looking
for forward slash
and the star so any url
and then two and of course that one will
be equal to
forward slash index html
again this is specific to react router
dom
if you're not using it then you don't
need to add it and we go with
status and 200
so we save it and check it out
now of course everything is going to
work once we deploy
our app because first when we're looking
for api
everything is awesome we direct to
netflix functions
and then if the react router dom needs
it
then we just navigate back to index html
so that's how both of them can play
together the redirect
for our amplifier functions and then
redirect
for react router dump and before we
continue one quick thing that i would
like to mention
is that if you take a look at the
package json
notice the build command so i added this
c i and then equal sign
and if you don't add that one you might
get some strange bugs where
the project works locally but then once
you try to deploy it on netfly
it's gonna spit back that there was an
error
so that's why i added it and also said
note
i added the code to the readme
so if you ever want to use it in your
other project just copy and paste
this line of code and you're going to be
in good shape
and once we have this one in place i'm
going to start
by removing a git repo because i think i
wanted to do that but i forgot so i'm
going to go with
remove rf and get because i'll create a
new one
and i'll go to my github even though i
have the tab open
and i'll say new and i'll call this
serverless serverless
func and react so
that's going to be the name of this
project
then i would want to copy these three
commands and let's just run
git add or sorry git init first
git add and git commit
and commit message is gonna be first
commit so and then i'll copy and paste
these
three commands and once i have
everything in place
i should see in the repo my project
now what's missing of course is the dot
env
of course right and that is on purpose
because we don't want to
share our secret variables so we're
going to go to netlify
and we'll spin up a new project i'll say
new site from git we're looking for
github
and since i named my one serverless so
we'll go
with serverless funk
and we'll have multiple options at least
in my case i'm going to have multiple
but and of course here it says
server less let's do it this way
and we should see the last one so i
don't want to deploy the star
i don't want to deploy the temp one what
i'm looking for is this
serverless function react
and then notice here i have right away
npm run build and
the directory is built and by the way
there
is a bug this one should be built
so let me go back then i don't want to
do that
i want to push this up to the github
let's say
tamu bug fixed
and once i have fixed my bug now of
course i'm going to do it one more time
where i'll refresh all right so we have
tamil bug fixed
and let's do it i'm gonna go with login
new set from git github
and we're looking for serverless server
less and the repo name was
serverless func react
and like i said we have npm run build
and then publish directory build and
if we want uh the environment variables
of course we'll get
the error when we try to deploy the
project
so at that point we can either do it
through the gui or we can add it right
now
and that's why i'll navigate back to my
project and we're looking for dot env
grab the key and pass in the value
and once you do that
everything should work i'm gonna go with
deploy site
now it's gonna take a little bit of time
so meanwhile i'll change the site name
and we're gonna go with serverless
funk funk and
react example
all right let's save that one and i'll
resume the video
once the build is complete all right and
once netflix is done building
our site we can navigate notice
this is going to be the simple setup
where we're just fetching data from
our previous serverless functions
project and then the second one is the
air table
where essentially we're fetching data
from our own
server because we have a serverless
function
and if we want to navigate to api
and then product of course there it is
we'll have our data and also our
redirects are going to work with react
or dom
if i navigate to a single product page
and if i refresh notice
there's no bug there is no error
everything works awesome that's how we
can set up our react project
with server list functions whether we
just want to fetch
data from some other
serverless functions project or we can
add a serverless function
to our react application and we're going
to be
in good shape